Wow E great keep it up proud of my
people hello it is Monday and we didn't
leave you hanging we never would that's
why we're back even though it's a rainy
day out here in Los Angeles it's a rainy
day out here in Los Angeles you can
always count on the H3 podcast unless
it's Martin Luther King Jr day yeah we
don't work that day we don't work that
day we don't work that day that day is
ours that's our day or well it's well
can we say that it's the country's day
it's not necessarily our it's not
necessarily our day I don't know about
the to the exact verbage of
that but I I honor it I love to honor
that day abely you do love to honor that
day um got a fantastic show here which
is totally unexpected uh coming off
there last
week um so we are going to it's raining
outside as I mentioned so we are going
to continue with our Stanley Cup
experiments versus my uh Hydro Flask
which is the one that I love and use we
are going to fill these up with ice all
the way and we're going to put it in the
dishwasher are we able to get the
thermometer in there Dan no it doesn't
work damn what the hell's the point of
that thing well you don't normally put
it in a metal sealed cage yeah it's
meant for for meat how thick is this
metal we're not talking about a military
grade washing machine well we're talking
about a $40 Bluetooth little dinky ass
you can't get through the cannot
we tried it it's also full of water
which also blocks RF
so yeah so we'll have to take it out
occasionally and well just shake shake
it gets hot as in there I know
that how hot is it inside a washing
machine it's hot I'm telling you guys
don't it's
130° that's hot
of you know Steam and heat that's hot
this is GNA be good it's not as hot as
fire but we're working our way up to
that um I'm going to stretch this out
the Stanley Cup legs Stanley Cup we're
really we're really right on the pulse
here with this one absolutely we have to
know uh we got that we've got so much
more let's just get into it you know
what I mean let's just talk let's just
start talking about it instead of
talking about talking about it let's
just talk about it I feel that I like
that dog me baby dog me baby what is
this I I forget how I came across this
it was on Reddit oh was on Reddit what's
what is going on here are these real
websites or are these just if you go to
news for my name there's like
five articles about me slamming David
Dober on five different websites this
has got to be some SEO scam right it's a
crossposting for SEO so what are these
websites
they're just nothing so it's what half
the internet is now well my guess is
someone writes an article and at the end
of the article they link their
website and then they tell all these
other this like massive net of website
to post that article that links back to
their website so let me okay I'm going
to see what one of them is the weekly
Journal I want to take a look is this a
real website they're literally all just
a
video These are AI websites
bro what is this is this even recent
okay yeah this from 6 hours Trump
celebrates to santis dropping out let's
see what's the quality here seems like a
real article not going to read it is it
okay so here you go H3 podcast Ethan
Klein Making a Splash in the news
everybody wow the the people cannot stop
chatting the people of Central Virginia
just cannot stop talking about Ethan
Klein
w
yeah so so thank you for honoring me
guys thank you you slammed him too
actually let's read the article
yeah can you send me a link I just have
the image yeah I if you search Ethan
Klein on Google oh I'm frozen oh oh for
real I'll do that Ethan Klein yeah then
no I
know no dude check out the news feed
look at me I am the news wow that's
you're so hot right now in the Blue
Mountain
popping oh here's one about my what is
sports SK is that a real website sports
sports a real one I see that one all the
time they wrote AR about uh my ending
the show with
Hassan that's pretty I mean you know
that's big news we're in the
news all right let's read this shout out
to ainson Globe oh it's a video yeah the
Ethan Klein just slammed David DOI
for not taking care of his long time
vlogging partner Jason Nash David do is
one of many creators with a troubled and
controversial history trending about me
it's what's trending wait that means
it's got to be on Twitter they're big on
Twitter yeah check to see how many how
do we do there go ahead what's trending
I'm trending you know one that's
trending
me that's right one of his videos went
horribly wrong and left a member of the
Vlog Squad seriously injured Dober has
pulled back from making videos and can
still live comfortably recently a few
vog Squad members vented about do not
fully understanding the financial
struggles they face now that he's
offline yeah he calls me to play pool
and I'm like I got to go live and and I
don't and I don't expect him to
understand that like I I know I've told
him there's also things that I like say
to him and I'm not sure if he hears me
like I'll say things like I'm losing my
house and he'll be like oh but just go
play
pool fellow YouTuber Ethan K reacted to
this and slamed for not helping out
Jason now considering the level of
financial stress experiencing no he's a
horrible friend like Jason he should
have set you up
nice after everything you guys have been
through I don't know what or how but you
should be rich you should be Rich too
right the fact that you're like I got to
do hours on Tik Tok to pay my bills
that's nuts
right is spitting wow super insightful
so there it is that's the news somebody
said them with the regular the world is
a
flame all right it didn't make its way
to Twitter apparently big news but the
Central Virginia yeah well that that's
these are my
people let's see um shout out Central
Virginia
we were talking about little pump dming
o models on Instagram this whole weird
underground scam mhm that we discovered
through Austin MC
Brom um we got these are all new ones
here yeah so we got we put a call out if
anyone got DMS from
them and we did there seems to be a lot
of
[Music]
um sex workers is that correct or or
would you just say an only fans model
what would you
say you could say sex worker you could
say only fans I think we have a lot of
sex workers in our audience I think so
too seems like it we respect them and we
love them 100% yeah and I got tons of
messages not just about them
specifically but about predatory
companies reaching out to them and a lot
of them were willing to to speak on it
if we it's a really interesting topic to
dive into yeah by the way my um our
Nanny that watches uh Bruce and Teddy
may she said I got you a present for
your birthday I was like whoa okay cuz
it's I mean that was half a year ago or
seven eight or seven eights this year
yeah
a yo that's awesome I love that awesome
it's
powerful
oh
nice I just want to give everybody a
chance to really take it
in I wanted to show you guys that but
I'm actually cold so I'm going to put
this on yeah I it was really nice I love
this it's like I love I love
it but then you
did point out that it was late for her
birthday and that's not really cool
right yeah I Spit on her I spit in her
face before accepting it it was in June
this
year soet thoughtful but yeah my
birthday was it was a while ago I threw
I was drinking coffee and I threw it in
her
face good
good my neck looks tiny it's like a big
hole maybe I'll do like that my neck wow
wow your neck looks massive now
yeah stunning whoa who kissed his old
nasty Pig s so uh anyway here's what we
got from our fans apparently this came
in from Lil
Pump Pump It Up
yo I'm not interested in joining your
Playhouse nice you're worthless he said
boy you are dumb as first of all
worthless how old is this man to be
still mixing up your and your uh he is I
mean come on bro he's 23 oh he's
pretty young he should
know he'll figure it out in the next
couple years I thought he was a bit
older 23 yeah I love that though he's
like hey do you want to join my scam no
thank thanks you're worthless all right
says the guy who's trying to
solicit uh successful people in the DMS
by being a fraud here's Lil pump
again hey how are you I see you do o I
do as well he does I do o as well do you
have a team my team does a really good
job helping grow pages and making more
money I want to see if you were
interested little
pump this is this is your life you used
to make you were in a video with
Kanye and now you're messaging of girls
trying to scam them this is your life
arguably still doing better than Kanye
though so now n Kanye's back he
apologized wait did we ever talk about
his apology we mentioned it Bri we
mentioned it we never translated it oh I
wanted to read it and then I wanted to
ask Ian do we forgive Kanye well why are
you asking Ian he's not Jewish do you
forgive Kanye I liked his statement and
the thing is I like his music are you
kidding me no I'm not I'm in I'm back
we're back baby no shot I thought it was
nice he apologized but I thought it was
nice he's not sincere obviously
supposedly he's putting out like a a
40-minute apology like a video apology I
think he is sincere I think he came
around he was going through something
and he came around and now he can he can
repair the damage that he's done right
Ian he deleted the apology too yeah I
didn't I understand why did he do
that why did you delete the apology
because because he didn't mean it he was
trolling he's trolling no he's not oh
wait it's still on Twitter no it wasn't
that wasn't a troll he just he posted a
photo of himself wearing a t-shirt with
the Neo-Nazi on it like two days
ago he don't get it he doesn't get it
don't be so gullible like you come on
you're not usually this gullible I just
like I just just a few songs that I like
to listen to of his who is this villain
W in this morning so it's just you know
it's
easier what the you
know I could literally anti-semitic
and they can't drop me that proved not
to be
true
actually um let's see though maybe he'll
become a great champion of the Jews
maybe he'll be he might he might maybe
he'll be the next
Shindler could be they I believe they
call him a right
H there's a name for him for for this
type of person a
righteous forus righteous go he should
have went with Elon on his righteous
among the Nations we call them how cool
is that righteous among the Nations is
an honorific used by the state of Israel
to describe all non-jews who for purely
altruistic reasons risked their lives in
order to save Jews during Nazi Germany
rightous among the Nations okay that's
Kanye all right that sounds like Kanye
for sure I was going to say he should
have went with Elon on his apology tour
he's uh I think elon's in did he go to
Ashwood today is that where he went yeah
he was in Israel and now he he went with
like Ben Shapiro or something
yes no comment what did he say again
that pissed everyone
off it was it bu oh yeah it was it was
really bad he was like uh someone wrote
something like oh yeah the Jews are you
know in charge of everything and he's
like so true so true Tru has been stated
he had to say it in a dorky ass way of
course only facts here my friends he
said this is actual
truth not the best response to blatant
anti-semitic conspiracy
theories to you but those are popular
these days so it is The
Fad once again I am not a part of any
conspiracy I've never been invited I've
never got a memo you know that's what
you would say though well okay you're
you're half Jew yeah so who are you to
talk you got the memo no I
didn't get the memo they I'm who's your
is your mom or dad Jewish dad and you
don't honor your dad well you love Dad
as you know if your mom is not Jewish
you are not technically Jewish soer I
got pass dude I don't observe
that anyway I didn't get any
invites well we missed
you a Zach you were there Zach took
cliff notes for me yeah
yeah yeah and I feel like I'm a pretty
high ranking Jew at this point I mean
obviously there's a lot of high ranking
Jews way above me a lot however if there
is some kind of meeting I feel like am I
at the level where I would get an invite
or not yet yeah you're top tier bro like
I'm influential I you know what I mean
like I could put out propaganda yeah you
would be in the cabal you would be in
the cabal I could put out crazy
propaganda yeah so like yeah but you
guys know if I was invit I would tell
you right I tell you guys everything yo
you guys will never you guys will never
believe the letter I got in the mail
today it had like a hand a red hand
stamped with blood instead of wax and I
opened it
up well we miss and it says you are
chosen and then it disintegrated while I
was holding it we missed you and the
crep loock was off the charts the kppa
yeah nice see in the tunnels baby we
meet in the tunnels under New York
City all right what are we talking about
we're talking about Lil pump Lil
pump um moving on he's got more this is
so embarrassing for you dude hey how are
you I see you do o as well this is the
same one he sent the other person my
team does a really good job helping I
want to see if you're interested no
response Austin MC
Brom just to clean it off my bad my bad
my bad for random DM a close friend of
mine close friend of your what him oh
him this lady yada yada we read that one
here's L pump some more
hey what's up look I'm sure you get mad
people hitting you up about of
management would you be open to at least
talking we've got a really good team and
we would love to hop on a call with you
and at least get the chance to explain
and show you everything so is this
going to be on the
call acting like he would be but I doubt
it doubt it but but that but if someone
says yes they're going to want him on
the call right that's part of what SEALs
the deal I have a this is so pathetic I
think he might be on that
call just to be clear that aome McBroom
the previous one we haven't read that
yet that was someone else that sent that
that was another that it sent the same
one too it's identical but to a
different person correct machine gunning
that outy what are you doing this
is you're green screen is this is
influencer Hell we've often wondered
what is the uh what are you doing do
he's got a chew he's
good I think he's trying to hide it he
loves hiding his chews look at him yeah
he's hiding
it so funny H he's such a
character um anytime we give him chews
he'll go try to hide his somewhere in
the guard he'll go in the backyard and
hide it yeah and then he'll go after
Alfredo's um this is influencer
hell
we've often wondered where's Rock Bottom
boogy uh has come close or is at Rock
Bottom
although he's not doing this I never
did right and I think you can put your
head up high saying you never did this
boogy beat my ex-wife and I'm also a
pedophile that doesn't sound great I'll
be
honest Lil pump hey hi what's up looking
for blah blah blah
ricegum ricegum's doing this A come
on I thought he was on a Redemption tour
dude what the is wrong these people
have
no that's that those are pretty have no
dignity like I know it's rice gum but
like he's having a kit or no they lost
it that was tragic I these are from
before that I want to point out I mean
still he seems like when he made that we
were pregnant and then when they
tragically uh when she tragically missed
carried or no it was a still birth it
was so sad the story was horrible from
what I've seen from him and I don't want
to put my reputation on on him but he
seems like a pretty good person now
that's what I thought when I there was a
depth of emotion when he was talking
about his the still birth that's a
that's that really uh affected me maybe
maybe turn around seems he seems really
really like a good person so you're
guaranteeing that he'll never do
anything up on my own name I take
this on my my shoulders all that he's a
good person he'll never do anything
wrong a good person never do anything
those laughs are hilarious Mr Ed
back
here whoa Mr Ed you
okay um the if anyone has any from 2023
or or sooner let's send him out
otherwise we're going to say ricegum is
been
uh he's righteous among the Nations
that's right mhm that's
right yeah I I it the the video was
truly uh heart-wrenching yeah it was
horrible do you make money off the
Instagram stuff like Instagram post she
said yes like promo paid or anything oh
I've made it like a small amount have
you thought about only fans no he's
trying to recruit them to do only fans
now you could make like serious money on
there this girl was making AK a month
and worked with us and now she makes
200,000 a month but I think you could be
good if you don't want to promote it we
can keep it lowkey it's up to
you bro this is even slimier than the
other where he's trying to like
pimp
them but no he's reformed we love him
pump hey hey I mean look at all the this
is nuts they's just
endless who's wet melons oh that's is
that one of the girls that sent it yeah
she's okay yeah Shout Out Wet melons
she's yeah she's a big fan of the show
friend of M elen yeah she's great we
love wet melons don't we folks w we love
melons of all uh levels of uh wetness
dry
melons Misty melons MH dewy melons it's
all popping the top of this list um that
was Tiger but that was all he sent her
she didn't
respond wow I've you know these
Instagram models girls whoever are
popular I hear they get
crazy DMS from famous dudes trying to
smash mhm
um yeah okay thank you to wet
melons love
that so shout out to uh the the absolute
pits of social media
hell
um this is amazing you
guys this is the greatest
ad for Sigma brain of all time
unintentionally I don't even know that
they know that this is our
flavor this is Miz I didn't know he was
supporting a brockly
assassin for those that
remember I feel like he's constantly
up his hair I feel like every
time I see him he has something wild
going on in his head that's the vibe I
guess so yeah I watched this whole thing
and it's so damn funny um he's at the
gym with all his homies and one of them
busts out Sigma brain and they all not
just love it but they're they're tripped
out about it being so good and
unusual this is an endorsement if I've
ever heard or seen one go ahead I got a
lot this is authentic
amazing this guy doesn't know who I am
also I'm sure he hates me with those
muscles well what flavor is
that you see where this says flavor
Sigma brain Sigma
brain if we made it just for these kinds
of dudes yeah our marketing worked we
reached our our audience don't see
flavor whatever we'll let it rip the
flavor is Sigma brain
brother I can't smell that at
all so they do pre-workout with gamer
stuff go I think two scoops is 200 miigs
let's do two 200 of what
caffeine when all those gos mama ain't
rais no wait does anyone do
pre-workout like what are they
doing it's probably just caffeine right
Prett workout Boost energy it's a so
they want the caffeine yeah got it nice
thank you sir yes
sir y let's go let's do it chat this is
big what is this my caffeine oh no it's
gu have a zip CH I whenever I see an
influencer referring to chat
unironically chat chat
I can't do it anymore the chat thing I I
with that I do it all the time everybody
does chat listen chat this is gonna be
huge
chatt maybe I'm just out on the you're
just a boomer dude man I have people
here to talk to chat this is crazy
people are going to make a compilation
of me saying it now yeah y exactly great
chat just feels more inclusive I feel
like than saying like guys or right yeah
okay we love Progressive AB
a he's not he's no longer AB he's ABC so
Progressive yeah whole damn alphabet let
me mix it than
you chat do you feel like we're doing
more today I feel like we're doing way
more now you point it out now it's it's
a lot never thought about it so look at
that color first of all gorgeous emerald
green straight from the
uh I don't know what flavor is hold on
he doesn't hold up so at first it seems
as if he doesn't like
but that quickly changes you see this
there or the yoga studio what the hell
is that I don't know you're smelling it
like you don't know you don't if you
should drink it or
not oh that is wrong I can't tell what
flavor it is be a sigma bro taste that
misc is short
[Music]
circuiting I can't tell what that
is yeah yeah yeah yeah it's jacked
up you want to try to guess it's
probably like a watermelon flavor or
something no you might be actually on to
something there it's absolutely not
watermelon yeah that's watermelon dude
it's got sour oh no maybe not right
it's weird I can't I can't tell what the
it is I I thought it was a first
sour
he loves it he's freaking out look
there's our trainers oh my
God Rob taste that and see if you can
tell what flavor it is this is our boy
the one who did
way a
gamer that's really good is really good
he says wow we grab that Z I heard that
really good yeah I can during all future
gamer Subs reads according to Miz really
good very good very I can't tell what
the flavor is though lime lime yeah he's
right he he he knows what's up he's a
pro dude he's seasoned you can tell it
is lime ultimately what they're tasting
I believe you got what science oh nice
yep keeps going though the whole gym is
buzzing about Sigma
brand yeah that's my favorite I'm going
to go steal some more though cuz he
drank half of
it so what is the entertainment value of
watching them assemble Gym gear well
they just opened the gym so just I don't
know the excitement of seeing somebody
build a business I guess yeah they they
just opened last week I don't know I
mean
they have streams on to hang out with
people anyway well is this like a highly
viewed stream or no yeah probably like
30 30,000 people watching him right now
I just feel like I'm not I'm not here
hating I'm just don't ha I'm a
boomer I'm out of the I'm out of
it you know obviously people watch this
show are way more attuned
with Real Entertainment see I shouldn't
even say that it's not real it's that's
real entertainment I'm not the
gatekeeper of what's entertainment okay
[Music]
Boomer guess the flavor guess it they
had to fill it up cuz you notice that
[Music]
they hit that they're sharing that
too
yeah the lightning just buzzed his
brain go
ahead is it supposed to be a regular
flavor just some weird ass name flavor I
have no idea oh it tastes like beef
turkey like sub tropical say it say it
like a cocktail on the
beach
T come on
Lime uhhuh I have no clue it's
like a tropical Berry that boy gety yeah
is there more I just longer than I
thought no should I keep
watching there's another one here let's
just let's go to him tropical Berry bro
what well mavor M if you see this pass
on the word that it is lime spicy L is
this gam y shout out wake wake Wilder I
love this guy he's Jack bro and he's got
nice hair he's the man he was my partner
for loot Goblin oh for real yeah we won
me and him I think he said nice things
that's why I like him
about our
[Music]
beverage getting kicked out by 12 this
guy's going to nail I could tell go on
yeah yeah
huh I know what this is It's like a
passion come on I put my faith in you
man I'll tell you what this is forget
about the gym this is the sigma brain
stream I mean they spent more time
talking about our beverage it's great
content yeah so there it is Sigma brain
love it shout out to mkff in the gang
chat that was crazy right chat that was
crazy that was crazy everyone in chat
type in we love Sigma brain CH
CHP I'm happy to announce that on
Wednesday I will be getting a low taper
fade no on the
[Applause]
[Music]
show I think I'm going to look good
imine if Ethan got
a can we just get Ethan in
there I'm going to remake it have uh his
dad find his dad saying Ethan just drop
that in there
Ethan Ethan e AB you look great with it
you look really good with that low taper
thank you Cam okay who's this I hate it
this is not me I don't know about that
looking pretty chatted out to me not for
me Dan
who is this man damn terrible you don't
like it
no I'd run my fingers through that she
get out of here she get out of here here
of course whoever did this chose me at
the Apex of my weight also was Apex that
was it I remember you think so I
remember when I wore this shirt I went
to my friend the photo that made you
turn it all around kind of it was I was
at my friend's wedding and I didn't fit
into anything so I had to get this
shirt and boy it
was good though looking good so we get
to see what I look like not oh my
goodness she looks like um there's that
famous girl with that haircut like
that ruuby Rose Ruby R who is Ruby Rose
she's in Orange is the New Black she's
an actor mhm I don't yeah I don't she
been in anything
recent okay we love it and Ian hello
dude fire sick looking more Adam Scott
than ever with that hair Lena this is
interesting oh I love it what do we
think about
this do we love it AB yeah she could
Rock
anything did she see this that Lena
should ride a motorcycle definitely BR I
think she saw
it okay we love
it she that was just love two weeks ago
so I think you look good buddy you're
being too hard on yourself I don't like
that one
Olivia Olivia something's wrong
something's wrong yeah I don't know
everything's going on here in my opinion
that's the most narrow head I've ever
seen in my life for real for real for
real for real for real for real all
right we'll skip over that
Sam she's not here either is she no so
okay and Zach Zach you look really good
bro M would you ever cut hair I used to
have my hair like that back in like 2016
do you maintain the length of your hair
or do you growing it out uh no I
maintain the length of it okay shantala
gives me a trim like every I don't know
seven weeks something like that oh so
you're on it yeah yeah yeah on it are
you would you ever go back to having
short hair I don't know if it's always
going to be at my length now but I think
some type of long hair will always be in
my uh my life and why is that it just
suits your who you feel you are as a
person yeah I think so I got you yeah
but it doesn't look bad I don't hate it
I don't hate it there it is so tomorrow
we are GNA have a barber come in and
give me that Wednesday Wednesday juy
Fade
up let
um tomorrow though we probably should
mention the uh schedule change wait yeah
Ian what happened cuz I have Jeff show
on
Thursday ah did we say we're going to
okay so I'll do both I said unless it's
live okay okay okay so we do THS
Tuesdays we do uh see you next Tuesday
we are moving those to Thursday starting
this week so there will be no see you
next Tuesday see you next Thursday from
now on and it's still the same acronym
so it's perfect no change required easy
easy on The Branding side so there will
be no show tomorrow with peace and love
for members see you next Tuesday is
being moved to Thursday with peace and
love peace and love the reason for that
is because we want more time to come
into the studio and on Tuesday to have
time for activities and fun Goofs and
stuff to film so this is the benefit of
everybody well put now that said you are
also doing something else on Thursday
this week right that you just mentioned
yeah so also I'm going on Jeff's show
okay I don't know if it's live or not if
it's
live I might not do my show CU I mean
you guys can watch me there I don't know
if that's but but if it's not live I'll
come back and do a stream is that fair
yeah I mean that's what you suggested
yeah I don't know if I I think I need to
might do have to do both regardless
what's up to you if you yeah sure yeah
would you guys let me off the hook if I
uh if I do Jeff show live by the way um
this is a huge show now this is
important everybody Google Ryan
Kavanaugh uh we were talking about our
website about Ryan Kavanaugh does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein
that's the American Finance here wait
Ryan that's the website does Ryan kavana
look like Harvey Weinstein no way he
said that huh yeah that's now that's a
drop I'm stressing it it was offline
last time and I just wanted to say
people in case they need to brush up on
trivia we're so back in case they get
confused about who who balls okay chill
Ryan um you can now revisit the website
we are protected with Cloud flare and we
are in we are entrenched and we are not
going anywhere I spent a considerable
amount of time on this this weekend of
well I'm scared cuz you guys are crazy
and there's too many people it's hard to
host a website that's optimized for that
many people it's getting old dude it's
not getting old Ryan you would it's for
me it's not for me it's not so anyway
Ryan where should the people go if they
want to brush up on trivia does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein
there it is do of
course can we get that sound bite on
like when you hit the the website can we
play that there is a SEO or is that bad
SEO that's a bad SEO to have
automatically but I can put a little
thing where you click it I can do button
clicks plays the sound wait so somebody
said Jeff FM is live on patreon come on
you got you got to make it live for the
people I'm going to ask to make it live
for the
people thank you okay well I mean it's a
little I'm going to say this it's a
little presumptuous to put a guest
episode live when he's I think that's
just yeah I mean if he's profiting off
it then like he's he's including me in
his business I think he normally streams
live and then re-ups to YouTube
right right but again do do not
understand what I'm saying you just want
it to yeah cuz it's like that's like me
asking a I mean it's not as bad it's
like me asking a guest to read a copy
read or something because I'm
participating in exclusive content fors
patreon but I got nothing to do with
that it's not exclusive though it's just
a the live is exclus release the live is
exclusive right I don't think it's that
bad personally I don't think it's that
bad to like have the live behind a pay
wall and then release it for everybody
else I mean we did something pretty
similar well we stopped because I felt
uncomfortable doing that with guests
okay well fair enough which makes me the
ultimate human
being
yeah I I agree it's not that big of a
deal but I would prefer if our fans
could watch it live so that I could
potentially well it doesn't hurt to ask
maybe he'd do that for we'll do it live
for the people right je live for the
people we do it live I think the
website is holding it's holding steady
hold the LI let's go dude hold the LI
thank
you um so good work uh good work z uh
love oh thank you thank you very much is
there how do you suppose we can work
that sound bite in uh bottom clicks so
okay oh wait somebody just pointed
out if you're going on Jeff's should you
just have Jeff give you a low taper fade
that's true true I mean I guess that
takes away content from us so maybe I
shouldn't suggest that but well I don't
think it's that good of content I mean
it's kind of it's pretty funny you think
so it's a it's funny it's a low taper F
think it's funnier for somebody who is
not a barber to try and give you a low
taper fade that's probably the fun com
that will not I mean I've already done
the shitty haircut I tried that yeah
yeah AB po AB what about me I shaved
your head last time I did a great job
you didn't do fade you just annihilated
my head how hard could it be no I tried
to fade up Ethan that one time it didn't
didn't turn out so well doesn't seem
very hard I could do it fades are not
something to take lightly Dan this
is school stuff it's not a big deal you
want to do it yeah I'll do it okay do it
I'll let you do it okay yeah easy I'll
watch your YouTube I'm not kidding do it
all right let's do it show me how good
you
are I mean what yeah I mean I kind of
get it you go oh eight six five whatever
right I seen him do it how hard could it
be all right so anyway that's on
Thursday let me see if he answered me
because I texted do it live I'm G to
text
him can we do
Thursday live okay for General audience
for the people
okay for the people
Ethan the what I
mean because I don't want our fans to
have to sign up for us patreon to watch
content that I'm doing you know what I
mean how about we stream it on our I'm
like Robin Hood in that sense we could
stream it for S stream his show on our
Channel yeah you know what I
mean just Premiere it live on our
Channel just rip it from let's make it a
member stream
yeah okay all right TI for tat
oh he says oh he you know what I'm gonna
say big props to Jeff the first line he
sent me because I said is it live on
Thursday he says it's not live on
Thursday unless you want it to be that
was his first message the guy he's
golden oh he's true blue wow he's the
man you really
is holy
okay he says he about the dating
thing I guess he was planning on doing
his own dating show so I got to work out
the details of where's who's dating too
but he says he has over a th000
submissions wow bro he
doesn't wow I'm shocked that this is
already off the rails going horribly
kind of that's the tradition of the show
no me and Jeff are going to work it out
he's the
man okay if you say so I have no faith
in we just went from 41,000 live views
to 30 Shout Out
YouTube it's not went to sign sign up
for Jeff P mhm I mean dude YouTube If
kick can do it then so can you uh
actually big news oh boy regarding
YouTube streaming we just discovered as
the show started today that they have
added user activity to Chatters we can
see a log of everything that a chatter
oh that's great that is amazing that
changes everything changes everything
and makes it so much better and what it
maybe means Channel
activity yo no way and it goes back for
years so you guys are not safe
anymore dude y'all are screwed if y'all
ain't nothing I'm going to click a
random here I'm clicking a random and
I'm scrolling way back way back let's
see something
up here we go hey
Raven why did you say that's so annoying
what was the date uh see you next
Tuesday number 19
what was so annoying and What's the
title of this next Tuesday Nexium
debrief
B kidding but that is pretty exciting
we'll be able to have really nice
conversations with Chatters now I love
that uh I
think so if we can figure out a way to
see that log outside of the live like in
the YouTube back end that would
potentially mean we could do ban appeals
oh yeah oh ban appeals are fun
that would be such a great segment yeah
that would be fun um you know I'll have
to see if there's a way to see it
outside of the
live yeah we can yeah they're moving in
the right direction we've been asking
for this for years from YouTube we can
bring content Court back with ban
appeals right true um different kind of
content court on that note if you are a
member right now and you are available
to check the content Court Discord um
Channel and our Channel I appreciate it
we're we're looking for material yeah
it's always good to Source the people
cuz you don't want to miss anything well
I've been yeah we've been working on it
this past weekend and uh I reached out
to Discord but not a lot of people saw
it I don't think so so the the subject
of it is not we're not saying it even
though if you're in the Discord you know
right but we're not we're not saying
who's the target yeah who's the uh not
the target who's the
defendant right right
speaking of enemies of the
show here is the omelet of
knowledge he's not really an enemy I'm
being I'm being dramatic with these guys
Abba and
preach
um apparently in Quebec he's like a
local
celebrity and he does standup comedy and
apparently people like come to his shows
and
stuff yeah yeah what does he talk about
the like break the
eggs it's like K where's the joke
brother wow you a okay come on go
easy on him go easy on preach we kid him
we kid him cuz we love him he made a
comment about your
boobies uh here he is singing a Michael
Jackson song and we we uh ran AI through
it so it's just his voice so we could
play it for you guys uh well so there
wasn't a claim on the original I'd say
we should watch the original oh no claim
yeah okay fantastic if you want to play
both I think we should watch the
original and then and then let's hear
just his vocals we should do his vocals
and then just uh squeak squeaky FL in
the
background okay let's see let's see what
our boys got I'm going to be I'm going
to be
open-minded yeah anyone from Quebec have
any details about his local celeb I'm
curious yeah I tried to find what the
show was called but uh I was not
successful I could not figure it out
he's flaring up right now all right so
he was talking about my Tourette yeah
yeah yeah he's he's kind of fair game
you know anyway go ahead
[Music]
omelette okay is this a singing
show we cannot find any
context that's so we can't find anything
about it but there's a whole ass room of
people is a whole TV crew
there's
[Music]
people well you can see the you can see
the network here it says dude he's he's
kind of he's throwing himself into it
that's what say it up he's throwing
himself fully into it I appreciate the
enthusias you can you can see the
network name here it's C Telly t e l e
with the the accent over the e
z I don't know how to say that any
cu fan fans know what this is let us
know anyway go
[Music]
on there we
go he really has it all he's the song
He's the song The Dance and the
philosophy I don't hate this yeah I I I
can't I can't hate this he's not Terri I
can't really hate on it either he's not
he's not a fantastic singer but he is
he's pretty Good's
and throwing himself into it plus his
fit is I dig his fit I got to give him
that he's doing the dance from the music
video I'll say this I like that he threw
himself I respect that and also there is
something that I want to I don't did we
call them Just for Laugh somebody says
in the chat oh so he's doing comedy uh
yeah well so and I'll point out too hey
I think I found it thank you just for
laughs was the uh keyword
okay so this it looks like it was from a
couple years ago at least this video is
frosted rap says hope everyone is having
an excellent day question for Ethan what
do you think of the name maximilan
August Klein maximilan maxmillion was
thrown out there I remember on maxilon
was that we were talking about I need
the max I mean along with along with a
billion others I um I got to tell you
I'm coming back around to
Scotty
uh yeah what turned you off of it again
well I was like I don't want to put that
on on our on our unborn child that he's
like you know named after you know a pet
obviously he's is it's it's not like
pho right yeah um but but what I saw was
and obviously Shredder is much more than
a pet to us he's he's a human being but
right but um I saw that Steve Irwin
named uh their daughter after their
beloved family dog yeah bendy so if if
it's good enough for
Steve then it's good enough for me yeah
yeah okay Rex is kind of dope though
wait Rex hold on did we hold on Rex is
kind of dope that's sick actually I knew
a kid named Rex he was cool I knew I
knew a guy named Rex also cool yeah it's
Rexford right that's the full name
Rexford I think so I don't like when it
has to be a full name you know I kind of
just Vibe with naming him Rex I like Rex
it doesn't have to be and it means king
like edus Rex oh that's nice not edus
though you someone El re the name of the
play
re
Mom oh yeah Teddy will love that if you
name him Rex I think he will Bruce too I
mean he's wait is Rex short for
something I think it's Rex well I see
Rexford is a name uh Rex is mail name
given derived from Latin yada
yada I guess Rex is just a name though
well you can make it one you can name
tyrosaurus
Rex T-Rex Tyran first name tyranosaurus
middle name Rex what about rexar rexar
Rex
[Laughter]
off all right um let's continue but I
was going to say did we call them red
pilled I don't know someone called them
red pilled but I'll say that probably
you at some point I think you may have
yeah they're not red pilled I like that
they're in touch with the with their
artistic side but karma you know what I
mean but
karma so I respect that about
[Music]
him yeah I was wrong about the red pill
if I said
[Music]
that this is still
fun oh my God so what's the is it a
competition is do any okay so the only
thing I picked up on and don't hold me
to this if I'm wrong but the the op in
that Reddit thread at one of their
comments mentioned uh maybe it wasn't
the op maybe it was somebody in the else
in the comments that knew what this was
from that the guy that they kept cutting
to was somebody that helped him break
into comedy and so this he was kind of
like hon for that guy maybe this this
whole thing was honoring that guy in
some way I wonder if that guy likes
omelets who doesn't and I mean he's
French Canadian probably those eggshells
I honestly didn't know which side
character I was going to see when I
clicked this the title is uh I saw fil
familiar face singing Michael
Jackson uh there it is y now let's
listen to the one without backing music
though just because we're douches and we
and we like to do them like that fair
warning the because the audio quality of
this video is not not great I mean it's
not it's not that terrific yeah okay
it's it's decent though you'll see but
I'll say this uh as a as a body of of
people we sending peace and love to
Omelette and we congratulate him on his
uh
appearance what the
[Applause]
sat
honestly it's not bad it's like he's
pretty good it's okay yeah it's pretty
good I was expecting it to be worse with
that but let's keep
[Applause]
listening
the future is so awesome that we can do
this like the future
rules this is so sick oh
[Music]
man wait I don't know if it was the AI
or if yeah he actually stumbled through
that no I think that was a a
glitch
all right now this part is turning into
a fever dream and it's making me
uncomfortable it's so funny every time
he does the little little dance with his
feet they cut away from his feet for
some reason where they don't want to
show it they just don't understand he's
just his sneaker game is crazy probably
they don't want everyone at home to be
feel stunted on weaking too loud
distracting but okay we we give it up we
honor omelet yeah somebody said he's no
Enrique and glacius in a good way that's
a compliment right yeah he's better
you're better than Enrique
[Music]
glacius now play that with his omelette
the omelet of knowledge together and the
squeaks give me give me one second to do
that I gonna have to juggle some
around here cut away for one sec uh we
have a new button slide we can honor in
the meantime oh no sorry not a button
slide a death
slide I'll just mute it these people are
nuts who's what what the who's
making these
slides well this one it looks like it's
it looks like it's hailing but Jesus
Christ what were they even
riding I I'm surprised they all got up
okay this is real look at this oh
it cut it he grabs the snot off his nose
oh I saw that yeah like I was like oh
damn that's real friend right there
well they almost killed their friend so
look at that and then he grabs it but I
guess we don't need to see that oh we do
need to see
that is that friendship or what that's
yeah I wouldn't do that for my I would
do that for my kids only H nobody else
you just don't have any real friends I
guess maybe Ela but she can do it
herself his friend looks like he's in
like distress maybe maybe he was like
extra worried he was laughing the other
dude was not Oh I thought he was
laughing he is not laughing this man's
crying no this guy's crying and he's
laughing so there it is
everybody in order to comprehend you're
going to have to break some hell
man comprehend in order to comprehend to
eat the the the omelet of knowledge
you're going to need to break those
eggshells
wow we honor you powerful preach we
honor you in order to comprehend you're
going to have to break some This Is Us
comprehend this is Reaching Across the
aisle and offering This Is Us offering
an olive branch in order to comprehend
you're going to have to break some a
testament to your skill to compr your
talent when we talk about burning the
witch you know the arrow used to burn
the witch Just One of A
never really sto in order
toak
CH in order to compreh eat theet so
anyway can we get to break those egg
anyway thank you uh for everybody
watching hopefully you see this pre it's
all love here
sheka all
right oh no this is so tragic we're the
line is falling Jordan Peterson was
officially lost his case against the
Ontario
psychologists uh who are trying to up
your discipline him
for being an being an
talking about patient I think
specifically it was not even being an
it was talking about his
patience public that was one of them
yeah like she speaking like poorly of
them which is wild so here Jordan said a
higher Court in Canada has ruled that
the Ontario College of psychologists
indeed has the right to sentence me to
re-education Camp or settled down it's
not a camp you probably have to watch
like a few videos traffic school also
you're not being forced you can just
stop being a psych psychiatrist you know
what I mean you're
not I'm I'm going to refer to uh when
you get a speeding ticket you have to go
to traffic school that's a re-education
camp dude it's so dramatic Jordan you're
being such a you're being such a Queen
right now you're being such a teis right
now Jor Geor Geor re-education cam what
are you talking about it's capitulate to
the petty bureaucrats and the adpated
woke mob or lose my professional license
again H he's such a liar
like it's not cool how he lies about
this because I feel like there is pro
there are
problems okay happening with like
wokeness going too far however this is
not one of
those he was talking about one of
his patients on public in public you
don't want what your doctor doing that I
don't so anyway he congratulates them CP
Ontario
CP huh you won this round mark my words
however the war has barely started there
is nothing you can take from me that I'm
unwilling to lose
you need to sit
down okay you have everything you're
super rich you have a massive audience
nobody's trying to take anything from
you and I love how easy he's like I'm
ready to lose everything when literally
he's he's risking
nothing he's risking nothing yeah
actually isn't that last sentence kind
of revealing there is nothing you can
take from me that I'm unwilling to lose
I don't think yeah I don't think he
cares about losing his psychologist
license he's benefiting from this fight
because he gets to cry to his audience
and get all the sympathy points that
he's being censored or whatever and he
doesn't even practice anymore
he's hasn't in probably five he fully
shifted into being a podcaster and a
social commentator or whatever so that's
true they don't have anything that they
can really take there's nothing you can
take from me that I'm unwilling to lose
okay then we're aligned yeah so like no
problem he's kind of saying it's all
good yeah it's all good I think it's his
Twitter bio he wants to keep clinical
psychologist in there that's that's all
he's fighting for it's not illegal to
time to remove it
buddy he could keep it I mean coming
after him for his Twitter bio you know
what I mean you can't talk you can't be
like yeah so I had this one
patient she thought she was trans but
she's really a
man I was sitting there judging
her thinking what an idiot she
is and I do that all the time all my
patients are morons they're
pathetic there's something wrong with
them I I film our sessions in private so
that if I get threatened I can release
it
publicly and show what morons they
are I one of my
patients several several of
them godamn it Ontario I've never done
anything word with my dogs I'm you can't
take anything I'm not willing to
lose
vagina he was sus he suspended his
private uh clinical practice in 2017
when he said his notoriety made it
ethically impossible to
continue right ethics is why you stopped
so like six or seven years since he's
actually practiced shouldn't you have to
like kind of stay up to date to practice
in such a like a high level sounds he
does yeah you know what I mean like you
got to you got to stay relevant but
anyway he's he's ready for war watch out
seriously you've been warned seriously
that's aitz you know what you need you
need you need some psych therapy from
the board let's get some board certified
therapists to talk to this man really
you are bored uncertified so there it is
shout out Jordan we love him
we're rooting for him we're all rooting
for you sorry s sorry beautiful
beautiful oh actually
though
Jordan he did he did predict the
downfall of Sports Illustrated did you
hear about that oh they gone well
they're gone under I
mean that writing's been on the wall for
like two decades hasn't it I mean what
magazine is still operating no they put
a chunky girl on the cover that was the
end oh yeah that was they were flying
High Sports Illustrated magazine was
selling like hot cakes until until they
up I wonder actually is he doing
a Victory lap on that I'm pretty sure
yeah so so I'd like to see that if he is
I told him no but it it was like a week
ago so it's probably about 15,000 tws
back um but I'll I'll I told them at
sports illustrator no
fatties did they listen to me no I hate
fat people especially some of my clients
are fat and I hate them oh we have it
this is the original one or no this is
no no this is the the victory lab
2024 oh my god dude you are not for real
right now massive layoff hit Sports
Illustrated I can't imagine why dude you
are
crazy that's like of course he's going
to do that though like that's so
predictable so pathetic critical like
thinking this is not the behavior of
like a fully actualized mature person
this is so juvenile she is also 500%
hotter than he
isord I mean infinite more zero sex
appeal Jordan Peterson has zero sex
appeal I want Jordan to tell me what
about him is
hot yeah he's got those cool suits again
all of his fans I think she's pretty am
I missing something I disagree the women
on the cover like that the first time
all of his fans are like actually my
girlfriend looks like this and I think
she's beautiful right he such a dick
like I wish that it would like this
would get through to some people that
he's right not all that and a bag of
chips not even a bag of chips
Frankly Speaking of chips who's hungry
sheesh always
brother I'm
starving
you're starving I
am I'm
starving you on subway I didn't eat
since yesterday
afternoon
W actually that's not true I had um I
knew you that that was definitely not I
had fruits this morning okay I had an
Asian pear and a few slices of
watermelon is that okay that's fine
that's nice that's nice pears are great
by the way my weight is stabilized now I
feel like it's at I'm at about
175 it seems like a great it seems like
a great weight for my goal was 170 I'm
having trouble getting there but I think
maybe I think 175 is good my original
goal was 180 so um well then you hit the
goal so I me I'm happy I am happy with
my we you a rest oh yeah people are
reminding me in the chat that that woman
in the Sports Illustrated is Steve
aoki's niece remember we discovered that
okay what the is with that guy he's
involved in every damn thing
everything's Legacy bro they're
everywhere but why what is what is his
problem he was with he hangs out he
hangs out with um Brian
Johnson the the live forever guy
stei does yes go to his page right now I
see him everywhere
why just he's a busy guy oh sure enough
five months ago look at this and
anti-aging diet featuring St once you
guys start seeing this you'll see what I
mean no stoki is everywhere you're I
I've definitely been aware of this for
like no reason though he just shows up
everywhere everywhere yeah start keep
your eyes open media the personality you
know
multimedia thing I don't even know a
single song of his I don't think he
really has songs I like that just kind
of like a he's like an actual like DJ DJ
like he DJs other people's music he
presses play so he's famous for that
yeah and well I mean we talked about
this last time but there's definitely a
a nepo baby thing going on here his dad
created Benny hanas and is super w super
rich so if you're rich you can just push
a I guess that's true I mean Paris
Hilton uh lots of hug DJ career Paulie D
now that said he he is well known for
putting on like really uh racist shows
and stuff so you know he built a
reputation on his own but definitely
helps let's see Steve can talented he's
extremely talented of course and fully
self-made DJ stop who wrote that
selfmade he did he wrote he's a
self-made DJ I mean he's ironic they
even emphasized they even emphasized
fully self-made uhhuh yeah what does
that mean that's literally not
true that's crazy bro right that and the
top he's also one of the most humble
people I've ever had the pleasure of
sitting with I'm obsessed with that it's
funny actually how oh that is funny how
biased that sounds I would write that
about myself yeah hell yeah I am the
most humble person I am fully self-made
and I'm the nicest person I've ever met
I'm the nicest person I've ever sat with
why is here this is my thread this is
from 11 months ago why is Steve Aoki so
popular he's great when he's great when
you first enter the scene his energy and
crowd work encapsulates you eventually
you grow out of that phase after you
realize he plays the same type of set
repeatedly yeah how do I know this
everyone I know who loves Steve aoke
including myself haven't been to a set
of his in seven plus years okay that
sounds that sounds about right for my my
perception very good but I'm seeing now
that your eyes are open look for that
Steve aoke and when you see him in
something share it the top five
D cam just said the LA Weekly's top five
douchiest DJs is Steve aoke on this
let's see who we got Cascade okay only
three uh Afrojack Steve Aoki number
three oh Testo oh no and then number one
Paul oen fold y okay what read the Steve
Aoki part it's not loading for me uh
Steve Aoki uh LA's own Indie dance
Pioneer has become just another purveyor
of over-the-top more daff Punk than daff
Punk crap house
damn you forgive him if he hasn't been
such an anti-d Dan culture
gadfly Jesus going a little bit hard
almost calling that gadfly that's
rud Steve Aoki if you want to
call into the show text us CU I want us
you to be everywhere plus here I think
it'd be fun and you're in La apparently
I'm in
La dab me
up all right moving on oh you know what
we don't have sponsors today so I want
to thank who you thinkk my
wife my wife my wife my wife Teddy
fresh.com excuse me God damn my
wife so many great things head on over
to Teddy fresh.com
um and uh there's a new drop actually
look at big zip I mean look at all these
be Burger King
shirt if you want to be fly at Burger
King you're just embracing that huh I
like that I mean I can't I can't say no
the people this that's all they see
right cam what are you
wearing uh this comes out Thursday I
think this it's like a acid wash yo
that's sick and also I got the choker
too oh I love that this comes out
Thursday though the jewelry is so I love
the jewelry that they make yeah they
supposed to te this is a bag this bag is
so sick um those beads yes that I'm
excited it's came out really good take a
b so so anyway this is all happening
on uh I think it's Friday
now did we say that what's the 26th it's
Friday oh sorry I just use the Friday 26
is Friday yeah we moved you you're right
cam we just moved it to Friday for a
reason that I don't remember this comes
out Friday get it then get on Friday get
on it then get it on
Friday yes
sir um
inspirational videos we got Jordan you
guys want to order food or mean uh what
would you like
Ethan what would you like
Dan I'd like fries with that you want
french
fries kind of I could eat french fries
that's a good vibe here's the thing
though it has to be close enough that
they're not soggy yeah that's true let's
get some close
fries close fries anyone anyone close
fries I'll with his own close fries
too get some PR sheesh AB you have are
you logged in AB cuz Sam and Lena aren't
here oh Usual Suspects aren't they
not but I think I just saw Lena
somewhere give me a
sec fries and we're hopeless
without dip sauce maybe I actually need
to pee so I'll be right back oh my god
get it together
man I could uh figure it out and then
forward to Lena whatever we decide to
get donation tab
sure uh let me hit some of these donos
um Dan look me up in their log I dare
you I already did it's not that nothing
special I did throw tomatoes a couple
times which I don't
appreciate look me up in their log okay
it's very mean apparently it was kind of
mid yeah kind of mid toe Alex and toe
nothing what did you think was going to
happen there are you trying to catch a
band
thank you for the $10 though uh lolat
donated 20 bucks and said Gordon and
then parenthesis Gordy or Donnie
Prescott Klein is wait what is
Donnie is Donnie connected to
Gordon Donnie nickname for
Gordon you just make that
up I see some people okay all right when
he gets back I'll suggest uh Gordon
$50 from Molly Rose I co yes I got my
booster I don't believe
you I thanks uh thanks guys for keeping
me sane or insane I don't know I was
just going to use this money to buy
clothes but donating it to the Shetty
cause instead also shout out Olivia well
thank you Molly thank you Molly remember
two years there that's cool two years am
Mar
Yoder donated 10 bucks said with all the
hype about these cups why not capitalize
on the hype and order some boba have
some Pals over and sip Boba from a
Stanley the hunger FF is holding for you
seems tame enough
yeah that hunger FF is holding is he are
you suggesting he holds it with his
or
[Music]
something H not sure not sure that could
be the conclusion I see why you would go
there uh $5 you guys playing power world
no um well somebody said they were Cam
said he was playing it yeah but then you
were telling about a controversy about
it this morning so I don't know if I
should admit that I've been playing it
but it's rules I love that well
I don't think it's like a controversy
that like you shouldn't be playing it
it's more just like how are these
not getting sued by
Nintendo for people that don't know this
game came out this weekend it's like a
kind of a viral hit just a million
people are playing it and uh it's a
pretty blatant Pokémon rip off
but they got guns so but it has guns uh
look at some of these characters it's
like there's not Pikachu there uh yeah
this is not
Pokemon with guns It's called Power I
saw I saw something about this rules it
just came out this weekend and it's
blowing up what's crazy what's the IP
violation uh well you know it's not
necessarily an IP violation because uh
these are theoretically original
characters but if you just look at it
it's it's called pow world and the
company that makes it is called uh
pocket something which is like it
literally like their name looks like
Pokemon and uh I mean it's clearly very
inspired by it it's a whole world you
collect these little animals in
balls it rules I'm probably it
in a week so but I mean they may have
changed it just enough to get away with
it but um well you know Nintendo's going
to try to and Nintendo will definitely
Nintendo is crazy uh litigious WEP so
we'll see what
happens okay very
good um let's move on
to new Alpha Male did we not watch this
guy before we have watched that guy
before but not this video this guy's
awesome he's back he's back baby oh wait
he was goingon to call into the show
what happened we got a hold of him and
everything he dropped the ball I forget
why he oh I remember he didn't grab yeah
remember we criticized him he didn't
grab Opportunity by the horns like I
still want to talk to him I I'm willing
to reach back out okay life sometimes
gives you a second chance sees
it here let's see what he has to say you
just got to be real with
yourself you've got to sit down just
like
andiz that you are a
worthless loser that's exactly
what I do come and once you realize and
understand who you are I feel like I
feel like true last year that would have
been me
true oh shout out to boie for taking
some of the heat off of you taking my
fat he's he's like that Meme taking the
fat hits for
me will be easy the problem is that
today nobody could admit that who they
are is wrong you could weigh 300 kilog
of pure fat and you still
wouldn't admit that you're fat look in
the mirror real and war with who the
you
are I mean obviously he's just a little
he doesn't know anything so
it's like I I don't want to criticize
him too hard yeah but like obviously
everything he said is not true like fat
people know they're fat trust
me yeah you're do you not realize you're
fat have you looked in the mirror yeah
that's if only someone would remind them
dude you're fat yeah anyway I would like
to talk to
him why I don't know it seemed like it
seemed like it'd be a fun combo
yeah but
okay we'll
see
um there's more to the
ninja oh this guy yeah people love this
guy my well died like three years ago
from Co
and he don't even know that
is he don't even know that his
grandson made it cuz I used
to I used to telling that I
wanted that man got me my first
get he saw me
where
bro
man got me my first
guitar and
I now when I'm traveling I can't even
tell you where we
are I made it in my job yeah I made it
in my
[Applause]
life I just wish I can see one more
time
beautiful emotional
powerful ain't going to cry on a live
stream I'm a grown man I
[Music]
got that's
sad
horrible imagine Ninja got a l table
face that's
funny that's where it came from
OT was really better so
um the guy's super talented he's got a
great voice really
good how the did he even think of
that like imagine if ninja had a low
taper fed like how do you even put those
formulate that sentence out of thin air
I don't know sounded like he took inspo
maybe from his grandfa father he was
talking about yeah
maybe maybe he was doing this for an
hour and a half Papa had a wa what's his
name I want to shout him out uh let me
find uh we said it last
week hopefully this guy gets some some
eyeballs from this because uh he's he's
super talented Eric DOA let's see Eric
DOA y Eric DOA here send me a link so I
can rep him all right I think it's time
that's his twitch
Channel okay here he is on Twitch Eric
DOA we love him and we honor
him is he live right now no this is a
video now that's the V
yeah uh who okay wow what the
terrible oh is he
live
all right shout out to Eric
DOA love
him the low taper
fade okay we are almost through top of
the
show um hour and a half in this one's
the last one it's a great little thing
online Pastor charged 1.3 million for a
crypto scam says the Lord told him to
take the cash for a home remodel for
sure Legend let's
go that sounds adds up for me I
mean charge you know Kenneth Copeland
said crazier than
that Caitlyn and I are being charged in
a civil charge uh from the Colorado
Securities and Exchange Commission for
basically selling millions of dollars
worth of cryptocurrency that is deemed
worthless by the state now the reason
that they're so hold on so they are
charging people people for crypto
scams yeah I guess so so where the
is what what's with all these YouTubers
running around like like Logan Paul
where's the where's the police they're
going after a poor man of God yeah look
how beautiful his house is by the way
those crypto uh monies did him good man
Lakeside gorgeous seeing that it's
worthless is because there is no exit
for people who have
but we launched an exchange The Exchange
technology failed things went downhill
and from that point forward it's just
been we've just been waiting on the Lord
literally for a miracle so the charges
are that Caitlyn and I pocketed $1.3
million and I just want to come out and
say that those uh charges are true so
there's thaty whoa dude you
just all right I guess case
closed it's kind of refreshing to see
that though because usually you know I
expect to be like it's categorically
false you know I appreciate
it3 million that's been yeah I took that
what yeah those uh charges are true
so there's been $1.3 million that's been
taken out of I think it was a total of
3.4 million but out of that 1.3 half a
million dollars went to the IRS and a
few hundred, went to a home remodel that
the Lord told us to do yeah dude the
Lord has good taste I love what he what
he's done there in that room beautiful
lighting I love the green chair really
really the Lord has some he has some
good taste high it's expensive taste but
good
taste just like Jesus Christ expensive
taste so how this whole thing started is
the Lord told us uh in 21 to walk away
from our marketing company and he said
I'm going to do a new thing oh this a
green screen
yeah and then he took us into this
cryptocurrency it was a different
cryptocurrency other than index coin of
the time well that cryptocurrency turned
out to be a scam that's and so the Lord
says give that to them but also give
them a 10x and I'm like well where's
this liquidity going to come from and
the Lord says lord said give them a 10x
that's some Gamba right
there what the is this dude this
world
is you can't help people from being
scammed there people are just born
dumb you they they say there's a su are
born every minute and it's I mean like
after everything we've said everything
people know about crypto this man is out
here saying God told me to give you a
10x and y'all are
in okay is trust me well as money is
coming in uh we would be sewing it and
at first it was hundreds of dollars and
thousands of dollars then tens of
thousands of dollars when it would come
in we tied we sew more money would come
in and so we were just always under the
impression that God was going to provide
that the source was never ending that
God was
and that we
had we sold a cryptocurrency with no
clear exit we did we took God at his
word and sold a cryptocurrency with no
clear exit and so the prosecutors have
to take that and say these people
willingly sold a cryptocurrency with no
clear exit well yeah and then but they
exited so that's the part that's a scam
I think we took God for at his
word yeah I know I I is he not
having a crisis of Faith it's kind of
God's fault well no that's smart for his
attorney cuz he's just going to plead
Insanity here you God uh kind of scammed
us wait Steve dude are you seriously
involved in this no come on bro I
didn't think Sor though he's very sorry
stoki come on man um yeah is he not
having a crisis of Faith he says God was
supposed to keep the the fountain on
forever God did and then yeah we had to
scam everyone when God turned off the
fountain hello what we're praying for
and what we're believing for still is
that God is going to do a miracle God is
going to work a miracle in the financial
sector yeah he's going to Good
Luck oh
who will be representing you in
court
God God God will you step up to the
podium please
the lawsuit alleges that besides the
home renovations they also had luxury
vacations cosmetic dentistry luxury
handbags and a snowmobile wow oh you got
to get that snowmobile God told God did
God's like yo get that snowmobile and
not the cheap one get the really nice
one the good one get the one with like
with the extra horsepower yeah trust me
trust me you're going to be so sick in
that God's God's badass bro
have you ever seen God do a keger
sick really good at it
amen all right well hold the phone they
raised 3.2 million from more than 300
individuals that's a lot from 300 people
Jesus yeah wait what the hell let me do
the arithmetic on
that where did they find all these rich
suckers that's $10,000 per person on
average maybe like a investor something
an angel
investor he's more like a demon
investor that's good I want to be a
demon
investor destroy it from the inside the
complaint alleges that uh raldo targeted
Christian communities in Denver and
claimed that God told him directly that
investors would become wealthy if they
put money into index coin
M oh man
well I'm glad to see that they're
charging people for
this you know that dude's
that man is going straight to
jail all right we should we should take
this J shete thing head
on oh no is that the coin well let me
see the edge it's green right now yeah
it's popping yo look at the back end
dude we might be seeing a
miracle God is God is back God is one
though index Cooper there's so many of
these coins I don't even know if
God is
watching it chart probably looks like
this up let's be real I mean
that's what's dink doink
at let's check in on some of our
favorites dink
D now that my friends is that is a rug
pull right there it doesn't get more rug
pull than
that I wonder if people are still
holding
I'm sure there are people that are like
well I could take this out and get 50
cents or I could keep it and have like
10 trillion shares right well you might
be holding for our lawsuit too right cuz
if you sell you automatically call be in
the lawsuit I guess or maybe I doubt
that but I think it it would be better
if you held it
yeah wow and people still trust this
guy is crypto Zoo still on there did
they I think they R they P was that even
a coin that was like some weird nft
thing wasn't it no there was a crypto
that was oh crypto Zoo yeah that was
part of the scam okay oh
yeah well this one was more legit than
dink D there's at least a few valleys
and Peaks you know
absolutely um very
good I look I look forward to his next
crypto Venture I'll be there
brother
always
love
you all right should we talk about J
shett it's tough it's tough to hear this
but I guess
so
um before I talk about it I need to put
on
my pendant M because he's not the only
one with beautiful
eyes I have gorgeous hazel eyes his eyes
are
like they're okay like here's the thing
about his eyes they look pretty good in
person but under like the the lens I
think they would look pretty dull pretty
ordinary whereas under the lens like a
camera lens yeah well you know in the
closeup I don't think like in a
photograph can Olivia can you help me
yeah yeah so
if like yeah that looks terrible man for
sure it looks pretty dull right if you
look if he did what I did like there's
only like eight or nine colors in
there if he did what I
did which is God's way to put your eye
right up to a camera and let them film
it mhm his eye will look like
thank you
Olivia he's a coward and he won't do it
but me I wear my eyes
proudly that's cool man that's awesome
can you zoom on
[Applause]
this you ever seen this there's a scene
in a Demolition Man you remember that
movie of course I do I love that movie
love that movie it's really good anyway
there's a scene where somebody he he
rips his eyeballs out with a pen and
then uses it to scan in that'd be funny
if Jay was one of like it's one of my
favorite gags if CU he has good eyes for
that all right now that I've shown you
guys that can we show this is this too
gory yeah don't show it okay yeah it's
awesome though that's a beautiful eye
too
gorgeous dink is my favorite coin so
here's the message you sent me and this
is this is just odd because it came out
of nowhere the last time I messaged him
was November 16 I said hey Jay you ever
want to come on the show and talk things
over it would be super
fun we would have a great Interac action
me and Jay I've seen it you do there was
chemistry it was electric a lot it was
when we took that
[Music]
photo our Rapport is insane crazy I
think he could get along with anyone
well let's test that theory with not
everyone apparently Let's test that
theory not everyone so anyway he
responds this
coward it doesn't say the date but it
was like a week
ago
he says happy New Year Ethan
scum hope you're
well good
punctuation he hit the apostrophe in the
right spot all the Caps period haha
nothing to talk
over
period haha really you write like
that
haha a little
snobbish okay who types out haha I'd be
like l lol like be one of be a person of
the people don't be one of these haha
people could tell he's just so full of
himself haha nothing to talk about all
love he said praying
hands well you're praying for for us
what does that mean yeah what are you
saying are you making fun of my religion
maybe I'm Jewish did did you know that
when you sent the praying
hands yo anti-Semitism shedy
confirmed I'm going want to say
confirmed I mean your eyes are 100%
ashkanazi Jewish Hazel and he can sense
that with his Aryan yeah yeah hey J
shett what the
now what the now star deeply into
my eyes you
[Music]
coward the all love it makes me think
that he loves you you know what I mean
but he I invited him on the show and he
said no maybe he's just
nervous where's part two this is it so
so where's the threat oh the threat is
in the praying hands cuz you don't know
there could be a knife there could be a
weapon you told me he clearly hold on
hold on before you defend J shett before
you defend J shett you told me he sent a
death threat mhm well I mean this is the
death threat what are you not seeing
about about
this what part of this is not a death
threat it looks like he's going to
karate chop your forehead that's what
I'm saying and with all that rampant
anti-Semitism going on in the world I
have every right to be in fear of my
life right now you don't think you're
being a little paranoid no he's valid
dude I don't see what what he got to
pray over yeah what do you got to pray
over my body what are you going to pray
at my funeral we're doing okay as of now
you're not going to come to my show but
you're going to come to my funeral got
it nice nice got it paying his respect
he's like I'm praying over your casket
which is the thread hold on this is J
shett
um this is J shett dude with his praying
hands give me a
break at my biggest haters
funeral you really going to do this to
me we had such good
rapport could have done a spectacular
show
together
but then you had to get all anti-semetic
[Music]
but like really what's the meaning here
he says I got to be honest it seems like
he was politely declining yeah your
invitation yeah I that doesn't I don't
know why you felt like your life was in
danger the hands bro the hands I told
you I mean that's generally that's like
a like I appreciate you you know so
clearly Namaste yeah you don't know a
lot those thank you for exposing your
ignorance he's a the sect of monks he
belongs to are Warrior monks and they
would they're known their tactics is
they would do the prey hands and in that
they would they would uh conceal a blade
that they could switch to for an
assassination pey blinders it's a PE
yeah preate is pre peaky wow it's an
ancient uh pre I didn't know
that that's scary and looks like a
swasti I don't see hands man right it's
just one of these away like it just did
like this this what do you use two hands
for to make a swast to come A Double H
hit there maybe yeah that that those
hands are ready to go up one's not
enough h
j one's not enough you had to put up two
hands it does take two hands to double
you're right you know oh no we caught
you you're busted boy do you think he
regrets responding it was nice that he
didn't ghost me he actually took the
time to respond yeah that's that's what
I thought as well um and I thought and I
thought he was being really polite but I
didn't I didn't realize there was such
malice you you got to read between the
lines haha nothing to talk about really
we have nothing to talk about you don't
think that we could sit in a room and
talk about anything like well I'm not on
this level
okay all right Joy
Oprah what's on the o list little pocket
knife playay people with you
[Music]
murder I bet you in his Wildest Dreams
he didn't think I could turn this into
like a 30 minute rant where I called him
anti-semitic
violent murderous murderous scam artist
did I say scam yet I don't think you've
mentioned any scamming hope you're well
who is he the doctor of death yeah hope
you're well Grim Reaper yeah who is he
mangala and why why happy New Year
wasn't last year happy or like why would
I need him to wish me a happy New Year
yeah what's what's that about happy New
Year I'll see you on the other side look
look at the first letter of each
sentence h h h a h h that's three h
laughing
Hitler adol hold on it's h
Hitler um myom hang hang
ass here's um wait I think there's a
code in there though it's it's three hes
oh no oh no not nor you're never gonna
beat the anti-semitic charges after this
buddy not after this okay now if you
want to come on the show and bury the
hatchet I'm willing to talk about
it but otherwise you're toast bud no
more Oprah no more Michelle Obama wait
wait are you inviting him on the show
after everything you just told me I'm
because I'm I'm a know I squash the beef
well you know I squash the
beef has he you going to let a lunatic
like that in the building no more
Michelle Obama no more Ellen degenerous
no more uh Kim
Kardashian okay your career is over
bucko hang ass I don't know what that
means
sorry um so I mean yeah what what else
is there to say
really well he clearly said it
all yeah I guess he said all it and more
man basically spit on my grave
pissed and tap danced and wished me
death made fun of Jews dud I'm sorry for
minimizing bad form I didn't really I
didn't have all the contact thank you
bad
form it's not good h h h somebody said
don't platform him I kind of inclined to
agree a guy like that
well listen this is an important
conversation I feel that we can oh this
is good hail hail hail Adolf
Hitler and then a karate
Chu and then I saw somebody in the chat
somebody in the chat said because
there's three H's it's H3
adios
oh yeah I thought that was good that's
scary adios you just wish me aios
say adios to that Gap deal cuz you're
done dude you're
over it was so cool to see him in the
windows at the Gap though have you seen
that in person he's everywhere he's in
every M was something yeah I go to the
mall and I see J shett every time I'm
there yeah
mhm
[Music]
no
yeah yeah all right I took it too far A
little too far I gave Dan a warning I
said this one might be too spicy and
yeah and it was it
[Music]
was but that's why we have the button I
take a shot and sometimes it's good
sometimes safety net dude are we doing
food like what
happened the conversation kind of
shifted we kind of petered out we didn't
have lean and Sam nobody knew what to do
nobody else knows how to order food I'm
here now if you guys need oh thank
God well it's three now are we going to
even have I well I'm I don't need to eat
I guess it depends on the spot is
grumbling
all right it we're moving on
it Shout Out J Shetty though he really
was dressed really well I thought he
looked he looked really good kid
super I'm kind of over kid super though
now I feel like he's oversaturated he's
like like all of a sudden he's designing
for Louis Vuitton it's like chill you
just got famous like six months ago yeah
we were just dressing J shett for give
me a break yeah slow down there bucko
here's chubbt is actually it's an expert
in human interactions because it's
scanned the internet so much um chat gbt
when reinterpreting the message Happy
New Year Ethan hope you're well haha
nothing can to talk over all love
praying Emoji with an underlying or evil
or Sinister intent for an not for a
novel so number one ignore all that
number one mocking
tone the sender could be feigning
politeness and good will happy New Year
Ethan may be dripping with sarcasm
especially if Ethan is currently in a
bad situation known to the sender mhm
I'm always in a bad situation cuz I'm
not
him hidden threat that's what I was
saying hope you're hope you're well
might be a Veiled Threat in the right
context this could imply the opposite
that the sender actually wishes or knows
of some harm coming Ethan's
[Music]
way
what he do good point Sinister subtexts
of nothing to talk over this phrase
could imply that some sort of plan or
scheme is already in motion and there's
no need for further discussion a plan
that Ethan is unaware of and could be
detrimental to
him all love with malicious intent the
phrase all love might be an ironic
statement in evil context could mean
that the sender's actions however
harmful are done under the guise of love
which is actually manipulative or
obsessive praying hand praying Emoji
hands is a symbol of
Doom in a Twisted way the praying Emoji
hands could be used to represent not a
gesture of Hope but a signal of
impending doom of a sort of final prayer
for Ethan before something bad happens
look at the get a l of this guy man
[Music]
yeah there it is don't ever talk talk to
me or my kids again get out of my kids
DMS oh sorry that's not funny they're
not on social media mm- I didn't mean
like in a sexual way that's not what I
was
implying it was I just I was doing the
meme don't ever talk to me or my kids
again that's a meme right sure sure talk
to me or my son again mhm clearly he's
obsessed with
me and it's getting creepy frankly Jay
it's time to move
on Beast so let's see we got Mr Beast
uploads his first video on X which is
pretty interesting I think I tied gameer
created Wily Walker we are currently
surrounded by countless
sharks here he is by the way this is
what he was
wearing how much you want to bet that
white shirt cost like 500 bucks cuz he
is that
smug what do you Napoleon who puts their
hands in their pocket like that just
chill dude he looks fire in that fit
though the fit looked really good and
he's very
trim his physique looks good mhm I don't
know if he's like has sixpack he
probably does knowing him and he's
riding the high from the conversation
you guys just had you can see it was the
report yeah he just dominated you he's
so happy about the
rort well to be fair we did meet him
outside the the red car remember so the
timeline adds up
mhm all
right enough Jay stop
[Laughter]
obsessing so we got Mr Beast we got uh
Stanley Cup let's do the Stanley Cup I'm
actually really I really want to test
that I think it well well the the blow
doesn't take too long this is just a
taste of the fires okay you got the cup
baby
okay so we have the Stanley Cups here he
is so fascinated by this here we've got
the Hydro Flask this is the one I use
totally sealed this is the Stanley Cup
that everyone's losing their mind over
now this seals right cuz it has a straw
so it does seal okay good so we're going
to fill them both up all the way with
ice to give it the best possible chance
of surviving the reason we're doing this
is because of the original video that um
created quite a dialogue
here it is this man had a car
fire goam it a fire yesterday still has
ice hey Danielle my name isy I'm the
president of wait wait when did this
hold on okay I didn't know this guy got
involved Stanley all
right fire yesterday still has ice hold
on she so according to her it was a fire
yesterday yep and they're still ice in
it I don't believe it I just don't
believe it I do thermod Don there's like
the laws of physics would have to be
violated in some way well it might have
been in the door it might have not been
in direct Flames I'm thinking sure sure
but then it was like a whole day later
too cuz I've had ice in my mind for
three days probably no yeah three days
yeah it'll last for long time well we're
going to find out
um let's see what this guy has to say
hey Danielle my name is Terence Riley
I'm the president of Stanley and we've
all seen your video wow what an ordeal
and we're all really glad you're safe
thanks for sharing the video because wow
it really shows how Stanley our Stanley
are built for life because what it went
through with you I couldn't think of a
better example I got to say this guy
sees the moment if this isn't viral
marketing scam this guy really excuse
the moment 7 million likes on this
this dude's selling more Cups than the
damn
uh the church
shop all right all right who sells cups
Bath and Beyond the aquarium gift shop
the cup store the ice cream place M got
him of our products quality but anyway
we're glad you're safe I've seen a lot
of comments that we should send you some
Stanley while we're going to send some
Stanley but there's one more thing we've
never done this before and we'll
probably never do it again but we'd love
to replace your vehicle yeah oh that's
nice all of us at Stanley we'd really
like to replace your vehicle so check
your DMs for details thanks be safe
cheers that's very kind that's nice yeah
you think he's going to buy a new one or
like a used one used yeah used I don't
know I think he's going to buy her a new
one can we we follow up with her let's
see if she got the
car everybody's so concerned about if
the whoops here's the whole video
everybody's so concerned about if the
Stanley spills but what about
mil a fire yesterday it still has ice in
it all right so bring it out so here's
the
stle fold to the top with ice you can
hear the jiggle okay here is the Hydro
Flask is there water in them yeah okay
they're both full of ice and water go to
the top of ice and then water over so
this one has less space but I think you
can probably hear that so here's what
we're going to do we're going to put
them in the wash yes turn it
up high heat high heat baby 130° it gets
in
there now that's
consistent
Heat we'll give it like 10 15 20 minutes
what do you think yeah I'd say that's
enough now my prediction is that both of
them will be fully melted oh I I doubt
they'll even melt like give
start maybe not fully melted but like s
significantly melted
sure anyone else want to throw the
prediction out
there so just K Kenneth Copeland thinks
they will burn
mhm um let me see if she got her car
though let me see it seemed like it's
the pinned one right the pinned video oh
she got it oh that's a new car oh
yeah that's sick what a okay hold on
what a journey thank you so much for
being here for it I can't say it enough
this okay
whatever hey you guys want to hear a
crazy
story guess we can start here yep that's
our car on fire that's a pretty serious
fire no we don't know what caused it it
just
happened and that's right after the fire
department left The Lunchbox you guys
love to talk about we were at the
junkyard the next day trying to get
stuff out of the car I went to go pull
the Stanley out of the cup holder and
noticed it still had ice in it
everybody's so concerned about if the
Stanley I think after seeing that video
I can say that it definitely took a lot
of heat yeah but it was an indirect f
probably it was probably for but not for
a long time mhm heat what do you think
you think it's going to live or or melt
Dan uh through the dishwasher yeah it'll
live for
sure let's give it more time let's give
it more time then let's give it 30
minutes
okay I just don't think it it'll get hot
enough in there to pierce all right iron
Veil listen if it can stay that cold in
130° um humid
environment uh that's
impressive someone says it's giving
insurance fraud hey spills but what
about
it where did you get 130 fire yesterday
still has i in it I I Googled it before
we left the junkyard I had hit 30,000 I
just said what's the temperature
inside uh I'm seeing ranging from 140 to
170 depending on the make model 13 seems
kind of a pretty good one we have a good
one yeah so maybe okay all right we'll
see what happens we'll see we'll see do
we have a manual ther thermometer
because you could put that in there and
then take it out and see the
temperature no I think we just have the
one we bought the other day all
right and got a DM from Stanley that
night that they were going to send me
cups but soon after that everybody was
talking about my video and it was in the
millions 24 hours later I got this DM
from Stanley and then saw what you my
name is Terrence Riley I'm the president
of Stanley but we'd love to replace your
vehicle yeah all of us watch this so
politely skip over
it thanks be safe
cheers here we are a month later and
this is my brand new4
Mazda
cx90 wait hold on if it's it has a
license plate on it already that tells
me it's not brand new oo
although it could be a
deal a certified pre-owned purchase
would also not have a license plate
probably right maybe that's not
significant could you zoom beautiful car
yeah you want to run the
plates might be I can't tell that might
not that might be a dealer plate yeah
those are temp plates it's 40,000 by the
way the car oh that's a really that's a
nice car yeah holy that super I
gotta say great move oh Mazda wait hold
the phone this is all marketing wait
hold the phone Mazda USA has the top
comment so honored to join your journey
Danielle we hope your Mazda cx90
rebuilds your trust in cars and elevates
the moment your family shares on the
road whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa did Stanley buy this or not doesn't
sound like it m probably donated that
okay now I'm very skeptical of this
whole thing and I know you're you're the
hater love are you sensing what I'm
sensing you think the whole thing's
fake I I think it's very possible yeah I
do it could be but I'm not convinced I
do think after the fact uh Stanley
probably just messaged MAA yo or I think
Mazda reach out to them they probably
saw that attention mhm cuz this this is
worth its money in Gold like giving a
car up for yeah both yeah both of them
it's crazy well either way I'm happy for
her the dude who's in charge of the
Stanley marketing is kind of a genius he
initially worked at Crocs oh he's the
genius he's the genius yeah and he like
doubled their sales like his first year
and then since he started he's just had
these insane ideas that have helped them
grow crazy yeah and they also happen to
have this crazy genius marketer yeah
yeah I think the video could have been
real and then he already has a connction
in the industry he could have reached
out to different car companies and said
are you interested and Mazda but isn't
it too perfect like a car fired they
don't know why it happened and the
Stanley Cup sitting right
there what's who's this guy by the way
um I forgot his name it's the guy who
was just in the video um it goes real
fast I love it I want to hire
him reach out bro I think you have hi
guys guess what today is new car day
it's my new car from
Stanley no no from Mazda what are we
doing here W your hands car it's
for more perfect ad I feel like Mazda is
almost doing like a Stolen Valor here
they're accusing Stanley of Stolen Valor
cuz everybody's giving Stanley the props
but Mazda they came in and they go oh
we we joined your
journey or or if if Mazda didn't pay and
they left this comment that's
crazy see now I need to talk to the
Stanley guy and find out did
Mazda donate this or not they for sure
did so then why is she saying thank you
Stanley well she might not be in on
it and look it's not even
melted I mean it's the same reason that
people think David do for the Teslas I
mean so that's my story oh yeah it's a
it's a fake license there you go Stanley
Stanley a
1913 my car caught on fire and thank
goodness none of my family was hurt and
all that came out of this was good
things it's a nice car a brand new car
and this wonderful picture of me picking
my nose no it wasn't really but it was
my favorite picture of the day and I
look like I'm picking my nose anyway
moral the story put yourself out there
make yourself vulnerable and you just
might get a free car out of it probably
won't be say don't commit auto fraud
yeah yeah burn your car up no I'm
kidding cool I wonder if they made her
pay the income tax on
that cuz she's getting a $440,000 gift
that IRS counts that as income right
it's just kind of wild this
company's been around for a 100 years
and now
they're getting super
popular as AB said there's something
going on there's some genius behind the
his name is Terrence Riley yeah he sent
the little blurb and that those are his
uh sales after he joined let's let's
learn about this guy 2020 Stanley
brought on Terrence Riley as its new
president oh that's the guy yeah that's
him oh Riley had spent the past seven
years at Crocs where he led the strategy
that turned the rubber clogs into one of
the hottest shoes on the market STS are
so in mhm
still yeah here's um since he started
here's Stanley's Revenue
are 800 million yep selling cups yep I
mean they're already crushing it if this
is 200 million it sounds looks like
they're at like you know 75 million or
something me
dude all right that's a lot of cups
if you're watching uh please email me
I'll give you everything I'll pay you
everything I
make sounds like it'd be worth
it sure pay him just pay him I think you
can afford him I cannot afford him I
cannot you might message us and say I've
been watching since the Israel days sure
Stanley I will pay you so much money or
not you Stanley the guy Terren I'll pay
you so much money if they're if you're
not making like $10 million a year
something insane talk to
me I can't pay you that much not even
close but talk to me but still talk to
me
yeah so um there you go I'm telling
people are saying this isn't interesting
this is
interesting and we're going to get to
the bottom of it and on Friday when it's
not raining we're going to burn those
uh it's theoretically
going to be dry on Wednesday I think oh
Wednesday we're going to burn them
huha Los Angeles what's the weather like
in Los Angeles I don't know if you guys
have seen the absolute
Mania happening around these cups this
is a holiday or a Valentine's Day sale
or something they're having and hordes
of women the wom the women love them
it's a collab Valentine's Day who's how
do you collab with it's a it's a special
edition okay yeah so I mean here they
come from all directions
oh there's dudes okay only the ladies
are running
though um these people they need this
Stanley
Cup I'm sorry it's Target collab for
Valentine's Day there's even an old lady
in there you see that even she's in the
mix I need it for my
granddaughter oh you think she's going
granddaughter points look at this lady
look at that she's power walking she has
walked that fast in 20 years
probably so are we just are we just
fully like if a kid shows up with a cup
that isn't a Stanley he's getting a
squirly in the toilet absolutely
no there's actually yeah there's been
like articles about that kids getting
bullied what I had so didn't we
talk about that on Monday yeah we talked
about a little bit yeah that they just
get spit on and cuz they're
broke poor you know what I should start
a charity where I give out Stanley Cups
to poor
kids that's we're changing the world
name brand water bottles we're getting
change in the world here
absolutely oh this is this video here's
more of people um mobbing the
shelves uh oh this is all taking place
at Target so this Valentine's Day one
was look how fast they go man mhm bro I
swear to God this is like bread in a
famine the way they're grabbing I need
six of these
yeah they had to change uh the LI two
per yeah says two per but you show up
with your whole crew your whole family
and each grab there was a few
left look at
that but you you we we went to B Stanley
no problem
right um yeah but we didn't get one of
the shitty basic
assas okay not a
collectors me man they're at the uh
front page of stock
how much is it going for um depends the
let me see the Valentine's Day one uh
Valentine's
Day they had a Starbucks collab one that
one is really that one's really hot
220 how much
$220 for which one the St uh Starbucks
collab and how much does that retail at
like 40 bucks 45 and then the
uh the target one's $94 lowest ask
apparently the people buying that did
not hear that Starbucks is being uh
boycotted you know what I'm saying yeah
no I was thinking if people want to get
one dearborn's a place to go oh true
yeah everyone's coming in from like uh
neighboring cities and striking gold
y I still don't understand the
the yeah so apparently uh Terren Riley
that's the was that the that's him mhm
so we delivered the car Stanley offered
to replace women's Vehicles a few weeks
ago is intended merely as a kind gesture
increasingly unkind World okay give it a
rest dude chill bro somehow our simple
act of kindness went remark somehow
uhhuh yeah somehow our simple act of
kindness went remarkably viral around
the globe who really knows why I guess
people everywhere are just tired of the
meanness in this world I don't like this
guy I all right the the offer can we uh
what what's his salary can we look that
up sometimes it's public as promised we
delivered the brand new car to
Danielle uh requested we did so without
a lot of marketing hoopla opting for a
simple little moment as the car is now
her story to tell thank you Dan you
can't dude this guy's a this guy's a
shark yeah this this this
is a bonified marketing psycho yeah
what's his last name Riley
ter Terence Riley um uh salary yeah I
couldn't find it I'm looking maybe he
owns stalk to get someone that big you
have to give them yeah right you have to
give them stock
yeah Oh wait so here here's some
info about it I'm trying to decide if I
can afford him or
not
um over the Lost blah blah
blah okay no this isn't about
him yeah
yeah he probably he probably gets a
shitload of of stock yeah I'll give you
stock we just wanted to donate these
hoodies as a simple Act of Charity why
who knows the world is a cold
place we didn't want to do a lot of
hoopla just to film a simple video not a
little
hoopla this dude out here this
I'd love to pick his brain
all right how long those been in there
uh they've been there for about 10
minutes all right yeah he probably he
probably let's take one out it's way too
soon it's been 10 minutes yeah it's
probably still just in the rinse
cycle yeah you're probably right
what's the Starbucks drama said someone
said they're apparent or I mean sorry
hold on let me acknowledge these really
generous uh gifts thank you so much to
Bella
Simmons nice to see you 20 gifted so
nice of
you thank you and Manny says hi 100
bucks thank you Manny they donated High
twice for $100 a hi back double High we
see you hi
Manny um Starbucks is being boycotted by
some people that say it's supporting
Israel and I don't there's no Starbucks
in Israel I know cuz I lived there and
it was
like it was kind of like a story that
they tried to be in there and apparently
nobody wanted they failed yeah faed they
failed to like get into the market yeah
huh that's surprising cuz like there's
even Starbucks in like Europe now and
you know the narrative early on in the
life of Starbucks was that they were too
snobby about their coffee to uh to
accept Starbucks but I think it's all
over the place now there's just I think
there's like beloved coffee chains in
Israel that they didn't want to uh
people just were comfort more
comfortable with I don't know why they
don't they don't make that Turkish
style true yeah it's supposed to be that
uh Starbucks um finances uh Israel they
send money to Israel but huh they've
denied that why would they send money to
Israel like for what purpose who which
which coffee company just sending them
money
does
Starbucks send Israel money like I mean
on face value doesn't make any sense
Starbucks has said that neither it nor
Schultz provide financial support to the
Israeli government or
Army why would
they right don't I yeah I don't know I
don't think corporations just give money
to governments oversee
governments maybe they do maybe I'm
missing it does Starbucks give money to
Israel those calls have generally
focused on two companies McDonald's and
Starbucks and though each company has
sought to distance itself from the
conflict and issued statement saying
they don't support our donate to
Israel's government or military that has
done little to Quil the
boycotts McDonald's too E I didn't even
hear about Mickey D's you can't boycott
McDonald's they could be straight up you
know what I mean they could have
a they could have straight up
crucifixions in their parking lot people
still showing up for those Egg
McMuffins you know what I mean
MH okay all
right there it is Starbucks ladies and
gentlemen
um yeah so there it
is what do you think about the fire test
you think it will survive
that
uh I'm more skeptical on that one direct
fire is pretty Next Level to be be
honest it'll be on hot coals which
essentially is direct fire yeah yeah
probably melt the plastic it there will
be melting for
sure um but I don't I think the actual
in
uh uh insulation part is
metal plastic piece yeah but the
outside you guys want to talk about
bivo sure I love
Vio I'm kind of late to the game I've
had this in the document for so
long um but I feel that I was an early
adopter of bivo this man was on my radar
before the
fame uh here he
is now when I found him I wasn't sure if
he knew why he was famous he does this
thing where he eats and he doesn't chew
his food and every time he swallows it
seems like he's going to choke to death
it might be hard for you to watch
AB do you do you feel that or no
[Laughter]
yeah what's the deal though he doesn't
choke he he like straight up I wish I
knew secr he's must have a fat
juicy there's been some not a
tight little hole like yours
yeah there's been some close calls with
them like I'm like yeah in his eyes you
can see so let's take a look
um yeah when I saw this it went viral
and I thought it was like an accident
where he just posted this and it might
have
been uh but it seems now he knows the
meme is to not chew so I don't know if
he became aware or if he was always like
this but here this is one of the classic
ones this one came out in December uh
3rd of last year
this big up The Hangover beef roast
dinner beef whatever listen we got beef
uh they are I don't know what they are
we got Pigs in Blankets we got a Yip in
peas potatoes par Snips or turnips one
of the two and um brussel sprouts but
split up so let's get into this you know
the rules as well Jamaican starle big up
the L virot thing actually rate this he
say you know the rules too but there's
never been any clarification about what
those rules are if you know you know you
know now it seems like the rule is no
chewing but it definitely didn't mean
that in the
beginning your man out actually he says
here the rule is put the Jamaican so
please kind of looks like me sort of
like Fus with Mr
Beast Mr Bean Mr Beast and me fuse we'd
be this
guy all right Chad's saying it too
really I don't see it yeah
AO that's good that's good oh it's
really raining eh God damn no leaks it's
a rainy day in Los we fixed the leaks
good thank God we fixed we had Ro we had
some roof roers fix I got up there t it
up T it just want to make sure their
work is good but it seems like it is oh
yeah yeah I looked around this morning
to see if there was any leaks very good
all right go
ahead just right at 10 uh whatever that
is I keep forgetting brush
Sprout Oh my God I seasoned very well
this one's very nice banging seven out
of 10 piging blanket sry again I'm
almost certain that he doesn't know that
people are watching for this reason at
this
point yeah I think he's just being
himself oh and it's it's the way he
swallows it looks like he's has he dying
his life flashes before his eyes every
time he swallowed something I've mostly
avoided this guy so I'm being why my
he's a sweet guy he's seems like a nice
guy not not against him or anything but
this is this is gross like I saw it once
and I was like oh that's gross and then
I've just never clicked on the I don't
know to me it's so funny it's so funny
you and everybody else in our group chat
SE very well big up the personal shift
aka the
dad beef going to just try and chew this
beef I'm going beef he's going to
oh this is going to be rough yeah he's
not the most elegant
eer but who am I to
judge his shoes way more than the dark
mad Cherry mad Cherry still s out of 10
suing well York we going to rip bit
off what is that thing Yorkshire pie
just
bread
this this one's actually not that crazy
I think you're right this is before he
embrace the meme you saying I think the
crazy part is the potato
here yeah oh my
God that was two yeah two chw swallow on
like a big ass po he's amazing that's
crazy one more time
dude one two who that's intense how does
he not choke frankly almost just one
shoe cuz he yeah the first one's a
positioning sh exactly yeah down
once get right into that look that bang
bang that's one chew that's one chew oh
my
God okay so it was the potato that made
him go viral he just dry swallow that
entire very nice seven out of 10 I how
you know oh pass how the how could you
have tasted that at all it's
crazy also the thing is God damn
boy you all right damn dude is he alone
he should not be doing this alone this
is how he
eats here he goes doesn't
matter big up hang Russian Roulette
overall 7 no I give it an eight I know
ra a lot of stuff at 7 but B up the 8
out of 10 on the dinner going to go live
make sure to come over catch in the next
one
Che so wow I love that he talks exactly
like Al
G true yeah so um this video
has I don't know a lot he's been blowing
up like crazy he has 1.2 million
now oh he another funny thing is his
teeth are always falling out and then
he's getting new teeth and then they
fall out oh no so that's a whole another
sub plot with bivo let's see this one
big up turkey big up UK 5 days later not
going to keep you waiting any longer I'm
not a miss the UK Tik Tok but Chee look
at that you know the rules listen bivo
turkey teeth what we say in rate them
down below they're definitely better
than a seven out of 10 big up the teeth
you know the rules but listen if you
ever want to get your teeth done drop me
a message big up UK smil as well message
UK Smiles cuz honestly 5 day turn around
got in Monday treatment started Tuesday
and I'm done on Saturday
nice bro took your teeth hopefully those
ones stayed in he was I don't know what
how it happened where it's uh falling
out all the time here let me find
it uh let's see so that's likely why his
chewing is bizarre right you think so I
think he tried to find it but there's a
video of him talking about him for some
reason in his childhood losing his teeth
and having issues since then so you want
some oh you think it's like a
teeth thing he's never explained that
but that is an interesting Theory also I
don't like that theory cuz it makes me
feel
bad well he's embracing it no of course
he is he's definitely embracing it but I
suspect that that's uh the origin of
that even if he's since had his teeth
corrected or fixed he probably wasn't
able to chew very well and so just got
used to just swallowing all which
yeah is kind of sad well we got he got
really good at it enough that he's been
able to make a Online Career out of it
um we got to get him on to call in but
here he is with he has a beautiful
girlfriend by the way that does videos
[Applause]
with um yeah Christmas dinner a gravy
you don't have gravy so I don't know if
these are the version I think this is
the first version
teeth they don't look as crispy she
don't like gravy so gravy all over let's
just get straight into it what you don't
like offit you just told me
so Pi she's had one
[Music]
already dude this woman is a gem like
she doesn't give a 10 seven
whatever it well whatever here's it
this is so funny here's AB taking a bite
of his
lunch now do you see the resemblance I
don't frankly I don't really I don't see
it okay other than the choking that is
good
though you
know have we reached out to him okay
good yes we have I really got to ask him
oh there was a donation he said um
there's nothing to talk about but have a
happy New Year all love all
love it's on dude he talked about his
jaw got up as a kid mgy said okay
yeah somebody uh sent a Super Chat
saying that
he uh let's
see where' you send that you send it in
the
main jaw got up as a kid maybe it
was a different one somebody said that
he got uh punched as a kid up his
jaw oh that's sad
um here he is putting in one of his
teeth what's happening guys be over here
I just wanted to make a video I his I
have to do when my tooth becomes loose
So currently it's 20 11 this tooth here
it's really loose oh sh out now watch it
shouldn't come out cuz it's
glued oh God yeah come out I'm going to
clean this up and I'm going to put it
back in with super
super now it's cleared up a bit there's
not much glue on it you can see a little
L but I can't really get it all off i'
be all day with me if you're if you're
working with glued in teeth you want to
minimize the chewing probably yeah huh
it so what I do is make sure my tooth is
dry out the back nice
sanitary problem is it's glue on the
back of my tooth I prey will have see my
DTI
soon this can't be like the way his
dentist told him to dry we get the glue
but we get the two this is the tricky
part cuz if I miss out I get all glow in
my
mouth oh yeah we don't want that just
clear the
top I love that he puts this all out
there I think it's really really cool
really I mean this most people would be
embarrassed by
this way oh way too much it's pretty
matter of fact about it that's good so
he said he put way too much does that
slow down that's brilliant and then we
go in we go for
it go we did
it you got to hold it in yeah yeah so
you want some
tee so he's holding it
in
yeah
he's back baby and voila voila voila the
toast back in feels a bit weird for the
minute is that just like really that's
another question can we write down stuff
like I need to ask him is that just like
industrial super glue or is that dental
glue okay you
know
like that I need to know this is an
iconic breakfast meal breakfast uh
Morrison's CF you know what's do ketchup
dig up the ketchup first of all got to
rate everything out of
10 here we go let's see if you get your
money's worth it's a bit cheaper in here
but you have to wait a long
time
mushroom that was a big
mushroom bit
watery 6 out of 10 fried
egg the baked beans beans I can't get
past
that baked beans that's like the last
thing I would want on that plate
bacon seems all right let's have a
[Music]
go well you with the baked beans
right
Ian it was proper proper Chu with
beans it wasn't that bad I remember no
but like mixing it with like all this
food we did the beans on toast we did
with toast
yeah not bad not bad six out of 10 Again
Ash Brown
that has look
good very Bland very he does like the
food kind slamming this place there's a
lot six out of 10 yeah do that one go
let's
go yeah out 10 again got the tea don't
have tea you're doing it wrong big up
the tea big up the bacon so that's be
big up the tea big up the tea big up the
Bacon High for one welcome viiv I think
he's an interesting guy he's a good guy
he seems like a really actually a sweet
guy um and that's why I love him that's
why I love
him he swallows a whole
carrot we almost lost bivo on the first
bite okay this one sounds
good bivo turkey I'm inan Burger King in
Turkey you know we G for the king beef
other than um not understanding English
at it it was so so hard to order this I
don't know what is in it the chips are
mad and the drink is mad so big up
turkey you know the rules let's have a
little
[Music]
go I how I feel about that it's
nice what do you mean you don't know how
you feel about it you I don't understand
how he tastes tury does he tast in his
throat or something let's have a little
go
I how I feel about that it's nice like
uses pressure to
foro that's like what the face I make
when I start panicking like is this
stuck in my throat do I
need bro bro is only feeling the
aftertaste that's the only taste the
aftertaste
[Music]
yeah I don't know I don't know with that
let's wash it down I I I think there's a
straw there it is that's our boy biva we
love him I like the little tilt to the
head he does did you find the one about
the that I asked for I'm not sure if
this is it this one is's talking about
his teeth saying that uh they're his
real teeth someone ask if they're false
they said you wait he's saying they're
his real teeth well this is probably an
earli my real teeth I might have a
filter on but these are my teeth it's my
jaw that's back
not my teeth people say oh your teeth
stick out this and that it's my jaw my
jaw should be here not there but I'm not
having surgery
B okay oh no I think he's just he's just
saying the issue is with his jaw teeth
like what makes him swallow like that
God damn why can I not find this one it
was so good he's like out on the street
and he's doing a Tik Tok and he's like
um I've never seen more natural
looking um uh implants or what do you
what do you call
them I don't know all right we love
you
bivo
[Music]
loveo big up um if we're moving on I
have an update about the preach
situation got some details go ahead from
the person who posted on Reddit they
messaged one of the mods with some more
information they said I'm the reditor
who posted the Preach video if you have
any questions I can answer to answer the
Cruz question the show is called uh live
from the universe it's basically a
weekly show where one celeb gets invited
and they put a show on for them
performing songs that are important in
their life guests are invited uh and
sing for the celebrity this week's
celebrity just started a new show with
preach oh yeah and preach is playing a
small part in
it and in order to comprehend you're
going to have to break
some comprehend in order
to
[Music]
eat preach is not very popular in Quebec
media but is definitely starting to get
more roles in part he's friends with
Mike Ward who's a very popular comedian
who got sued for a joke plus Mike Ward
has a
podcast and has the record for the
biggest live audience at a podcast
you're going have to break and guest who
have that record preach himself I guess
was there
with is a coin sorry I'm very
French and can't type in English oh you
did well you did well bre very good this
is my favorite song right now I'm I'm
converted he preached to my
soul need to break I got a buite that
omelet that omelet of
knowledge so is is PR going to leave
Abba in the dust sounds like he's
getting big over there like AB is not
doing TV shows and stuff
well do we know that I didn't know that
preach was doing TV shows until I saw
this clip so because I always thought it
was Abba was the alpha he was the alpha
wolf uh he definitely talks a lot more
in their videos but I think
um you know I think English is preach
his second uh language so he's proba a
little and and frankly for a native
French speaker who learned English I
mean compare him to xqc that dude is
barely literate he's definitely far
more accent we love preach that's a
pretty low bar but yeah what happened
should have happened love from what
should have happened happened and love
from the H3
Nation all
right should we check the
cups how long's it been I think it's
been 25 minutes is yeah 35 let's take a
look we can put them back in but let's
take a look okay so bring them here try
not to shake it AB just bring it here it
is what it is all right so we are
stopping it how's the heat is it hot
back there it's really hot he
says AB is grabbing
both of the
bottles he's not jiggling them as to
contain the
suspense so here's one now the outside
of this is hot that thing's warm
and this thing too it's got a lot of
heat in there all right let's start with
this
one oh there is there's let me open
it you know it's hard to tell you filled
it up does it have more does it have the
same amount of Ice uh it looks about the
same yeah yeah easy easy clap no problem
just drinkable water oh that's tap it
was just from the tap yeah just put your
finger on it La tap water is not it I'll
drink it I'll drink it if like it's the
middle of the night and I'm yeah
exactly that sounds like no problem I
don't think yeah I don't think the
washing machine's going to get uh-uh not
enough for this
[Music]
well here let's open it and you can
tell me if this
is here I don't know how to open
it well it probably it's probably
probably expanded from the heat it's
probably pretty hard to unscrew it right
now it's just wet I think it's just wet
it's just wet it's just
wet wet so anyway we're trying to get
inside recording but uh uh opening it it
probably it passed the first stage both
of them did both of them
passed trying to get the Stanley Cup
open so that we can examine the ice
levels that's an issue I have have with
my cup the plastic expands and gets imp
I got it guys I got it open dad Dan over
theread
yeah that thing is full ice all right
dude we're gonna we're gonna burn those
yeah that's the real me man I
mean I mean that you have huh what
something about Mega Man I have grown up
with Mega
Man okay I don't know what that has to
do with what we're talking but I like
Mega Man Too do you like Mega Man more
or Mega Man X which one are you a bigger
fan I think X was the this a Super
Nintendo uh series was that was the the
crowning Jewel of the series wasn't it I
think so personally you like X I'm I'm
an x boy x is way better it's like just
better it's just better in everyone yeah
I have grown up with me man
yep all right so we'll we'll wait on on
Wednesday to burn these
down we should do like what 5 minutes
over
coal 5 minutes and then put it back well
how many uh like a straight up fire yeah
how long do you think the carfire
burned probably not that long car fire
more than five minutes yeah more than
five 10
minutes so you want to do 10 minutes are
we trying to keep the Integrity of the
test here that's why I want to do it in
like careful intervals
I guess throw it back on after Che yeah
okay we'll do 10 minutes if you analyze
the video I don't think it caught fire
the straw isn't even melted mhm so I
don't think it got that hot the straw is
whole melted yeah so I think see this is
my opinion is we're going to stick it
over that thing and all the stuff at the
top is going to immediately start to
dissipate good okay the straw is bent
actually it's slightly bent but okay if
it bent like that it was definitely yeah
cuz it's a strong here I'll bring
it but like at the end of the day that
couldn't have been crazy hot for it to
just bend slightly so the
straws I mean if you look at everything
else that's melted in the car sure seems
like show this it was pretty hot in
there if you actually look further
strong straw I see if you actually look
at the video I went super close and it's
not that damaged it must the roof might
have caught on fire and then stuff fell
well you see well hold on you can see
the car on fire the top of the steering
wheel a little bit but down there at the
gear gear stick gear stick isn't burnt
really in my opinion like the
actual Center panel I mean here you can
see the fire I thought the fire looked
pretty serious yeah but I think it's
from the engine
and I don't know if yeah let's see it's
in here I think at the very end
um this is all after effect oh okay
damn it you just there there it is find
it no this is someone's saying the straw
is silicon would which would make it
super much more resistant well it's
silicon what's its what melting point
way higher cuz they do like Silicon they
do silicon like Oven stuff true
2500° F how much
2577 de F 2,000 melting point of
plastic does anyone have a lighter that
means if I put a lighter on this it will
not melt not even close think I might
have one in my that's the raw material I
bet they mix it with a bunch of
make it flexible this says that the um
the melting point of plastic is up to
200 degrees I got
it orange flame range this is good thank
you orange flame thank you ranges from
1,100 to
1200° White Flames are hotter measuring
1300 degrees oh that's Celsius what does
that translate to to about 1500 Celsius
the brighter the white the higher the
temperature well this is a cool flame
this
2,732 oh that's melting point yeah but
this wouldn't be that high this is going
to be like 11 no definitely not what's
1,100 C to
F
2012 oh I'm sorry I miss when I said
definitely not I was confusing
fahrenheit in
celsius like I
wonder what are
we keep in mind that's toxic don't this
is so like if there's any you can see
what it looks like
though it's definitely noticeably
charred it's charring it but you're like
holding it right on there well it was
just ambient that's from the butane or
whatever and that's Char does it feel
bendier it's hot I don't want to touch
it but it melted really fast too so I'm
not sure about the Silicon
clim I can't hold it straight got this
I started having Tremors in my
hand fire a kid at recess found a
lighter try to bend it does it does
itame of fire a butthole yeah similar
effect can breathing silicon fumes uh
let's see damage you no I'm sure it's
fine nothing is on fire I repeat nothing
is on
fire I mean that's a similar effect as
the
video kind of kind of let me put the
heat like pretty far away from it and
see what happens so wait a minute wait a
minute that's really quite far I think I
think we're barking down the wrong tree
here well we're investigating why
because hold
on I walked to the bathroom for a sec I
came back and I thought you were try and
crack again all right I'm not doing
direct flame we're
revisiting I'm not doing
it really careful about breing that it's
definitely toxic did you find any intel
so that the material that this is made
out of the melting point it varies
depending on the grade of silicone so
generally ranges from a thou from a
th000 to
2,577 which is what we originally said
it could actually be significantly lower
than that this thing melts very easily
yeah so maybe it's which is in line with
what I'm
saying well it's definitely a type of
plastic using cheap materials a
Stanley yesterday still has ice hey
Danielle
so so I don't know what it means but our
straw evidence is is not supporting what
this straw evidence
is like the bend I don't know why that
would even happen based on the
experiment I just did it just bends over
I think ambient heat I think the roof
wasn't to fire uh the if you look at the
gearbox is slightly slightly melted oh
here you can see the fire there's a
closer video on her account
here it happens right here at the
top that's a pretty Ser you're right
it's the engine where was ab and all of
this true you Fu this is on you AB I was
at Target trying to get
one okay all right all right well we'll
see we're going to burn
ours um is is is
breathing
silicone fumes
dangerous I mean yeah it's like it's
plastic oh it say it says it can
irritate nose throat and lungs but it
doesn't say like cancer well it's just
it's more in that TR for sure
that's just silicon silicon tetr hydde
can affect you when you breathe in
contact can severely irritate and burn
the skin I'm good on that breathing
silicone can irritate maybe next time I
won't Freebase it
no I'm I'm
fine uh
and all
right Stanley Cup Stanley Cup ladies and
gentlemen we've got um they going to
sponsor us now or what after all the
marketing we just did for them bro
there's a so many people that should be
sponsoring this show real God
damn
um we've got the somebody uh sent a
Super Chat and said I have the Mazda CX5
and Stanley's don't fit in the cup
holders LOL
huh that's a
wrinkle but that one fits perf maybe
it's the older version or maybe the year
matter well the CX5 was the new car I
don't was the original car also a Mazda
I don't know no well they said they got
her the same car was a Kia the first one
it was a different car yeah you don't
want the same car that just lit on fire
let me open it and confirm that Juju
they put they put the drinks in the
drink holder so well fit but it could
have been doctored yeah we just don't
know those de somebody else
donated $5 and said a 23-year-old C girl
was just arrested with
$2,500 of stolen Stanley Cups in her car
holy what's the story I want to
know more she got she got busted like
how' she snag that much merch she's
still they're pretty expensive so it was
probably just like
they're 40 bucks something I mean that's
a lot 40 bucks that's like a lot of Cups
a lot of
money 2500 divided by 40 I mean that's
yeah 62
cups it's a lot not that impressive of a
hall oh dude look at this you know
how when the police arrest like drug
dealers and they put out all the drugs
and weapons for like a really cool photo
op that makes the police department look
good well welcome to 24 baby the sting
of a
lifetime oh my God they did not they
they spread it out they took the time to
arrange that I stand behind her that's
what I'm saying free my girl free my
girl who's the C social media M they
they know what's up nice arrangement
nice arrangement that's a juicer pick
yeah it's a good social post for reals
yeah I guess the street safe right here
so that's $2,500 worth of Cups right
there damn okay that's like the D least
dense item per money you can get you
know what I mean so much air you could
just get a get a PlayStation maybe way
easier let's see comp uh police in
Roseville Northern Sacramento said
Sunday that they were called to a
reported theft from a store on Stanford
Ranch Road so she was just stealing them
like just wow that's a dedicated
Thief staff saw a woman take a shopping
cart full of Stanley water bottles
without paying for them oh come on
that's it the suspect refused to stop
for staff and stuffed her car with the
stolen merchandise oh this was her Hall
all at once
how not a good thief actually quite a
rookie rookie stuff
here so okay we've got Michaela fake tan
drama nagaro nagaru how do you say your
last name let's do that Michaela Nera I
think
Nera think it's noera noera
noera
noera what where's the where's the no
I'm just freestyling I don't
know it's n i let's let's just go with
Michaela yeah I didn't want to say it
but yeah
babby yeah if it if it sounds similar to
a slur I would never say then I
apologize that was not on purpose noera
yeah no we understand yeah I realized
after I said it I was like oh I
should button that but I
didn't but I didn't say it right no you
said her last name I did not say the
word and I would not say that word say
something I don't I probably shouldn't
say watch Keem star's like Ethan said
the
nword he'll cut it up nice oh yeah Ethan
slips
up Ethan is what oh the quartering he
always says uh Ethan
meltdown the quarter is a low IQ inbred
loser it's pre brother so we got the
Micha one we've got the
uh this one's good girl got $150,000 in
funding and she basically committed a
fraud and then she made a video this
one's funny I want to do this
one um business this girl she's a
business Guru on Tik Tok and she makes
she makes videos trying to help other
folks be successful business people
too God bless
her she her account name is
businesswoman PS
Milan wait this is hold
on oh this is the original post this is
is
her this shit's still up yeah oh
whoa it only has 50
likes this girl's droing yeah it has
like over 400,000 views though which I
think I think it was a quote tweet of
this that went viral
is so um well this girl is giving all
those Alpha Bros a run for their money
cuz this is straight facts so here
listen yeah actually and we should
preface this by saying yes this is
financial advice you should listen to
everything that she says in this video
my girl knows her she has a licensed
fiduciary fiary you should definitely do
this take all of this to the
bank except not now my student she says
now my student with no job got
$150,000 in funding to cloes on her
first Airbnb this woman has no credit no
job and she got $150,000 loan how was
able to get 15,000 airbn on her first
Airbnb and she didn't have no job no Pro
for income and she had no re she filed
her LLC on the website how toart an
llc.com in her business okay the first
thing she did was have an LLC and then
she built her relationships with she
opened a
business she opened a business checking
account with Navy Federal PNC Bank of
America and citizens and more for 30
days DNC Bank of America for at least 30
days she didn't have to buy no tra lines
have no net 30s or List herself or even
have a business address the way she was
able to do that was she applied for
every product that each of these Banks
had on their website and then she
liquidated the credit card to put down
on her first Airbnb if you want to do
the same DM business yeah so she's
describing a known it's a known illegal
scam called like
circular payments which I guess is when
you artificially increase your credit
score through financial fraud
essentially huh um so she thinks she
figured something out but well she did
she just described a
[Laughter]
crime and also also I love how loud the
music is in this like tutorial
video The Vibes are really good my girl
was able to get 150,000 in funding just
to close on her first Airbnb and she
didn't have no job so lame too like she
she gets she
essentially gets a fraudulent loan and
then buys a property an Airbnb
an Airbnb hell yeah that sucks that like
sucks that's like the worst in her
business okay the first thing she did
was have an LLC and then she buil her
relation Banks like Navy Federal PMC
Bank of America for at least 30 days she
didn't have to buy no have no net 30s or
List herself
the way she was able to do that was she
applied for every product that each of
these Banks had on their website and
then she liquidated the credit cards and
put down on her first airb I feel like
if you're going to five different banks
getting all their products at the same
time that's like feels like a
scam you know some your spidey sent
should tingle when you're sitting there
with like 50 credit cards from five
different
banks um here's our Tik Tok that's not
fraud it is actually pretty sure
that's thank you here she is uh living
life how I should
investor
um so I wonder if she's
responded where's the one where is this
video is it not on Tik
Tok
um the link says her Tik Tok and
then you know let's see this one how to
get let see get a 2021 or
2022 how to get a 21 or
22 Mercedes bird your credit fill out
pre-approval with
bank okay tell your dealership only run
your credit card with the bank that
pre-approved you rent out your car on
Tio and drive it for
free wait
what she's renting it to her self is
that what she what is she saying turo is
like a uh it's like Airbnb for cars
right oh okay
yeah yeah all of this is predicated on
like basically juggling this in
such a way that like he's have like with
the first thing with the Airbnb she
takes out like 40 credit cards and like
and liquidates them all into cash and
then buys a property and then I think
the assumption is the profit from the
Airbnb should be able to pay that off
but it's going to be at like 21%
interest rate or something it's like no
if she no if she gets
a so here's the thing if you get a
residential loan the rates are good if
you get a commercial loan it's a lot
more there's no way she told him it's
for commercial purposes which is fraud
too right right so she probably has a
decent uh uh interest rate however this
is the wor such bad advice I mean you
are you are wait wait wait you're saying
like no she didn't even get a loan like
that she bought the Airbnb cash no she
got with a loan from a loan no she
didn't get a loan she got a bunch of
credit cards and liquidated them she
said how do you liquidate a credit card
with QuickBooks she says it in the video
yeah no no no she's like doing like Cash
Advance on like 30 credit cards which
does a higher interest rate usually
although I think she had a trick for
that that she got around you know what
once they all consolidate it with a debt
collector those people will negotiate
she might be on to something everybody
start scamming your Banks y'all
okay what she's doing is I I I could be
misinterpreting some of this so tell me
if you guys got a different uh something
out of this but she's doing like that
old trick where she's applying to like
70 credit cards at like the same instant
so that they can't run a credit and see
that she already has a bunch of other
credit cards open you know what I mean
and getting like a shitload of them
approved all like $11,000 or $1,500 or
something liquidating them all into cash
and then using that to buy
Airbnb and then hoping the profits from
the Airbnb will allow her to pay off all
those credit cards that's what I think
is going on what is this video here the
Ben's got toled which I'm guessing God
she did fraud for sure yeah that's what
I was going to say this is probably an
insurance job oh no my Benz is total but
I love life dude there's no way this
girl didn't burn that herself yeah let's
think of how to dig ourselves out of
this you're telling me wait hold on it
just burned in that empty lot no it
probably got towed there maybe it got
towed there I don't know oh my God
this they're going to make a Netflix
movie about this girl one
day um Let me listen to this
again I think you might be right Dan I
think you're right first Airbnb and she
didn't have no job no prop income and
she had no Revenue in her business okay
the first thing she did was have an LLC
and then she built her relationships
with multiple Banks like Navy Federal
PNC of America for at least 30 days she
didn't have to buy no tra Lin have no
net 30s or List herself or even have a
business address the way she was able to
do that was she applied for every
product that each of these Banks had
product every credit card like every
type of credit card that they offer and
at like 20 banks at the same time okay
hold on let me so can you what does this
actually mean liquidating a credit card
through QuickBooks you know I'm not I
have aook EXP
I think that they
have some way
of doing a cash advance from a credit
card if it's a business card but they're
not going to give you that much like I
could get a cash advance for my credit
card
but well when you do it that's the thing
is she I think she found some workaround
with QuickBooks because when you get a
cash advance on a normal credit card
it's like 40% interest rate it's like
stupid like it you should never do that
unless it's like a total emergency but I
think she's somehow found a way to get
the money out of the credit card into
cash at at least like the normal
interest rate on that credit card which
is probably still really high or she's
paying 40% interest or yeah I don't know
but she I don't think that she doesn't
think much about
consequences she's just like we got the
air
tomorrow holy smugs
man yeah if anyone finds out what that
means I'd love to
know
um let's get the car let's get the BNB
guess I think QuickBooks will I think
they have like a a service or component
of them that acts as like a shortterm
lender but but they take a credit card
as collateral like who's do taking that
on that debt is so risky who would do
that QuickBooks
apparently that's she said she did it
here she she seems like she seems honest
she has a business online business
school yeah business women LLC welcome
to business women University Bridging
the Gap between women and Financial
Freedom oh no girl not this way don't
Bridge it like this are you struggling
with lack of funds lack of support lack
of Education somebody in the chat said
she's using QuickBooks POs to charge the
cards to her own account oh that's Mega
fraud yeah that makes sense that's super
fraud so she's charging herself and then
getting the money as if oh that's super
legal okay that that's that's some
girlboss dude don't hate so she
women she sends herself invoices from
her LLC why do you hate women so much
Ethan you got me I have no
answer oh this girl's nuts if yes
please keep scrolling Business
University is a mentorship program that
helps where I will teach you to do
Financial crimes and film them to put on
TI great detail if I did this that is
exactly the photo shoot I would do
too this is wild I mean I appreciate her
entrepreneuring spirit but girl right
not like this
please you will learn marketing credit
repair business funding Airbnb you will
learn Airbnb car rental business real
estate me she's a jack of all
truths oh we got testimonials time to uh
haven't yeah check the
audio God all these people are going to
go to
jail no these people are all yeah
probably they're all committing fraud
happy people this is
crazy oh here's they have screenshots of
the uh approvals congratulations you're
approved for 25,000 at 177%
okay and then she sends herself an
invoice dude that's
crazy this is nuts that this is just
online still TW here's 12,000 from US
Bank 25,000 from Navy Federal 6,500 from
PNC Bank here's another see that one
even says the CR it's
17.24% a yeah yeah
yeah which is so really high for that
much money right so imagine spending
$150,000 buying an Airbnb at 17% plus
you committed fraud to do it here this
loan is from
LLC green line of credit they're giving
her 50,000 who knows what's the the
interest rate on
that so hold on do let me do some math
um 17 somebody said it's not fraud if
she's pretty they got a good point that
is so true such a good point that is so
true ladies and gentlemen of the
jury what would you say she is on a
scale of 1 to
10 let's go if eight or higher she must
be
acquitted maybe a
seven six is pushing
it well you you you'd be surprised how
many girls got father issues and
granddaddy
issues 6% or less we will be pursuing
the death penalty
70% so see the chat asking are we 100%
sure this is
illegal what's the joke can they really
want to do this are we like are we sure
this is
illegal well just I mean here's the
thing if you were going to do this crime
here's how I would do it okay this is
horrible cuz everything's on the books
you're going to get you will get
absolutely here's what you do if
you really desperate for some money mhm
do this take all the cash take out the
cash and then you just got to like leave
the country and never come back
right just find a country where $150,000
can get you by for long period of time
yeah maybe you can get more I mean you
who knows if you have decent CR it's
probably important to check that they
don't have extradition with the United
States too they're not going to exate
for that they don't care about that I
feel like okay they would they would if
you came back they would they would know
right for sure right but if Financial
crime no extradition you stole less than
a
million I doubt they would go through
the extra you're right process you know
do you think they give a reduced
sentence for girl boss crimes probably I
think probably sure yeah yeah depends
which state she's in yeah I think so I
have a friend in Israel who did that
girl boss crime he he did he just took
out ton yeah fraud he did he took out
tons of loans uhhuh like hundreds of
thousands of dollars cuz he was like a
model he was like a normal citizen he
had a job he was totally fine and then
he wanted to move to South America and
become like a iasa guide or some
which he did do end up doing yeah but he
he took like $200,000 and then he just
left and he can never go back huh that's
pretty cool and uh so he outdoing IA in
he did do that I I don't talk to him so
much anymore last I heard he spent a few
years down there grew a rat tail and
then moved up to uh somewhere in
California he's doing something here and
this is bad
how I didn't I didn't judge it I'm just
saying it happened sounds like the guy
got the
life yeah throwing a rat tail out doing
I yeah I didn't I didn't give any value
judgment saying it happened I'm sorry I
apologize yeah thank
you oh man that's crazy so I did some
calculations 177% on 150,000 is 20
5,500 25 that's just your interest every
year that's your interest every
so that would be
2,125 a month just to cover the interest
that's not that's not the uh right
principle right right at all yeah which
means it would incre well no if you pay
the interest it would stay if you're
paying all of the interest it would just
stay stable yeah but so I mean that was
a tiny Airbnb and I don't know what oh I
do do we know what city she's in I don't
no assuming it's not a super expensive
city I mean that are 150k it's
definitely not so what is that's going
to get you less than $100 a night for
that for a tiny Airbnb like that and a
low a not super that seems like it would
probably be tough to keep occupied at
all times you'd have to keep 100% even
at 100% occupancy at $100 a day it would
be oh you would make enough you would
make just enough and you would have
extra oh if you had 100% occupancy
everybody's happy the bank is getting
their 177% interest getting payments on
time you own property but here's the
thing if if it's a victimless crime true
if for any reason and there are tons of
reasons why you don't have 100%
occupancy you your life will be
catastrophically ruined high risk High
reward baby yeah she had no job no
credit mhm what you got to lose oh look
ducky sleeping on the green screen guys
look at that so cute oh the audience
needs to see this he's so cute he's the
sweetest he really is such a good dog
it's a good boy he has such a chill
attitude about
everything he's dreaming a little bit
too his paw moving he gets his Z's in
here cuz he's just when he's home he
just wants to play all the
time he's I I'm so happy he's the best
dog he really
is he's so sweet he's so
chill
cute look at that that's what I'm
looking at right now oh man he doesn't
complain I mean he's just he's so happy
he's got a little sweater on turtleneck
so
cute yeah this morning he cuddles really
cute in the bed he came up to ELA in the
morning and he sat on her head like
where the pillow and her head meets at
the top and he was just sitting there so
cute what's so
[Music]
cute all right well shout out to girl
bosses everywhere shout out keep slaying
girls we love them mhm watch out for the
log girl you're here um oh no after the
video went viral people started tagging
the banks on Twitter snitches they
replied snitches get stitches y
um First Bank don't ask for proof of
income on a credit card oh this is her
she tweeting this yeah this is
under the original video yeah First
Bank does not ask for proof of income on
credit cards ask your Banker it's 0% APR
for 12 months oh that's good actually
then although I mean the 12 months will
end and she spent 10K on this specific
investment
not 150 on this property she got approve
for 150 but only use
10K yes you need wait what does that
mean she bought a property for $10,000
or or down payment who the going
to give them a mortgage after this who I
guess
because
theoretically all those credit cards
were open under a business l no no you I
don't think you can do that you can't
open credit cards under a fresh business
I remember when we said that she that
was what she said happened when we
opened our business I remember they're
like you have to build credit before we
can give you a credit card on the
business cuz you're credit separate
right that would be sensible but I
believe in the video she said after 30
days so then that's possible if the debt
was on her business right then she could
get a personal but that's also fraud
because if she's doing a personal
mortgage and using it commercially yeah
it's piercing the the corporate veil I
mean she's she's on a time crunch I mean
what is it 30 days before the bureau
updates so she probably did it got no it
it upsets immediately now oh it does
yeah no I think yeah I think what I was
saying earlier is how people do it if
I'm actually surprised it still works at
all in this day and age but this I'm
presuming she's literally filling out
all the applications and like
simultaneously turning them all in yeah
just got to be dude this is bananas she
is she is committing so many crimes she
must have had like 70 credit card 800
FICO scored uh someone in in chat says
we have a business with zero credit and
got a cash card so there you go I don't
know I'm seeing that it is
possible cuz I think they're they're all
relatively low amounts too there is no
chance and it's just a ton of them
there's no shot that this doesn't end
horribly like even if oh for sure even
if you don't get arrested let say and
everything is going as you planned in
terms of scheming this there's no shot
that you won't end up totally in debt
destitute right yeah not if you you uh
rent it out for a year then set it on
fire true true
true is this the girl math I've heard so
much about TWP speeed S I haven't heard
about girl math you haven't mm-m
like a
meme girl
math oh
man ela's asking she should take ducky
home with
her sorry I'm typing Ela says
yes wait oh that was you Lena you type
that okay got it yeah she's asking if
she should yeah take him
okay uh
that's a really fun story I really like
T untangling all that yes you need a
good personal credit to get approved oh
and once you get the money you will use
QuickBooks to take the money out of the
credit card and not use cash
advance that's the fraud it will take
her six months to pay off the debt and
then she will profit
how six months to pay off the debt you
can do the same with no income but good
credit comment business women if you
need help
the Airbnb project projected to make 2K
per
month 2K per month so that's like
70% vacancy at $100 yeah that seems
Wishful I don't know how
how how the Airbnb business is
but so she making uh 2,000 a month the
other 140,000 she can use to put down on
more airbnbs real estate or her own
business great if it's only 10 then she
get 15 airbnbs yeah e
see uh someone tagged I believe this is
documented criminal Behavior being
committed on your bank thanks for
letting us know I'll pass this along to
the appropriate
team you guys might want to look into
this oh damn this person's a hater yeah
Astro hit by pitch is
hating they even tagged US Bank and ask
oh US Bank you guys might want to look
into this and then they responded too
thank you for me the attention all the
best Bank of America
responded oh she's
GG well we wish her well we we're
rooting for
her and girl boss Nation rise the
up we're rooting
you girl boss Nation all right we got
time for we have time for One More Story
we have and you guys can
vote oh Kanye apologies the Jewish
people's
one that seems I mean it's old I was
meaning to talk about this forever ago
old we kind of talked about it
already
earlier yeah I guess
so
um well go ahead I was going to also
suggest I have a bunch of super chats if
you wanted me to hit some of those I
kind of need to pee again why don't I
hit a bunch of the super chats
[Music]
why don't I do that how bad do you have
to pee right now here I
go
uh let's see a female fogger went live
on accident after announcing her dog
pass she seemed forcing her child to
pose for the thumbnail while he is
sobbing we've talked about that that
happened a while ago yeah unless it
happened again possible that would be
wild if that happened again but thank
you uh thank you Kate
um if you would hit you must have quit
oh that's
good that's good if you would hit you
must have quit
nice uh see is this the girl math I've
heard so much about yeah I think so
right is that girl does all that count
as yeah sure kind of yeah yeah
okay
um
to would the crew be able to post a link
I'm going to bring this to my job bank
regulator hell no you kidding me I'm not
outing
her do your own
work thank you
though you could probably put it
together from that segment the clues are
all there uh I work for bank and this
would be flagged yeah yeah I I
imagine the classic
Roseville light
work that's Classics Roseville light
work does anybody have a clue what the
context of that was
no okay oh is Roseville the uh where the
cups were
stolen oh it was it was it was it was
there you go let me um there was one way
earlier in the show the guy that just
said hi with the $100 had previously
sent one he said with more of a message
what was was it Nate what was that name
it was Manny
Manny I
get I get
Nate uh proud member of 41 months here
keep it up crew and thanks for all the
Goofs and gaps over the years shout out
to the family also had some baby names
up the sleeve tried to stick to the o
theme Jackson or Jax
Arturo Arturo is a cool name Xavier oh
wow Wyatt
anybody ever known a Wyatt I like that
name yes Oscar I like the name Oscar
Cooper I love that name Cooper cop I
only know why it's fun to call people
cop like that would be a fun nickname to
have you guys what's up
CP C cly news about a baby name is
congratulations Cody Co and Kelsey they
had their baby oh they chose the name
that's been at the top of my list
forever which is Otis Otis Otis reading
little Otis running around well shout
out to Cody Co and Kelsey right yeah and
Kelsey congratulations congratulations
um that donation from Manny by the way
was
$200 and then he sent another $100 later
where he said Hi and then another $100
here you should hear this cuz uh
remember the the the high donation yes I
think that was a
mistake they had a $200 donation that
said they're a proud 41 Monon member wow
thanks for all the Goofs and gaffs thank
you they suggested the following baby
names Jackson uro uro I kind of like
Arturo but isn't that like that's name
that's like naming him like Muhammad or
something isn't it isn't that like a
Mexican name well you were going to name
him Scotty are you Scottish I don't even
think it's
Scottish really I think it's English
because as a half
Scott Scotty or I have an issue with
this no Am I Wrong is it like is it not
weird to name your son like a I feel
like yes like we talked about this with
like the Japanese names it would be
weird if you pick like a really Japanese
name for I like Arturo too I think it's
a cool name but like I'm not I can't
name him like we were saying like uh you
know japedo or some
what what about Alonso isn't that
the same Alonso is I was G say weren't
you suggesting some that were somewhat
Alfonso to me seems less more neutral
like obviously
doesn't count if it's Italian but Arturo
is like hardcore I feel like Arturo
might be Italian as well actually maybe
Arturo maybe it's Spanish there's a lot
of Swedish people called alons Al alons
alfons I like yeah uh well they also
suggested Xavier Wyatt which I thought
was interesting here I I just pull every
person named Arturo that's coming up
let's see Cuban Chilean Spanish
Guatemalan Mexican fente is a big cigar
brand so you been can name him after
cigar um here how about this can I name
my baby
aruro if I'm
white well just because it's span I mean
there are lots of white Spanish speaking
people too there's probably white all
over the place true you're right there's
white people in yeah yeah so if I'm I
don't think you should I think you need
to name your son
uro
all right uh or Xavier or Oscar Cooper
wait I do like Arturo though and I do
like Cooper you like Cooper I do saying
Cooper cuz the CP is like a really fun
nickname well I love agan Cooper that's
always been one of my favorite
characters and um from Twin Peaks uhhuh
Coupe yeah yeah also called Coupe that's
I guess that's where I'm getting it from
I'm sending the ones I like to El
actually so wait uh where is it
did Ela come and get ducky or did that
not happen I think so uh
out uh so anyway
aruro aruro I like coer I
like and then what was the other one
Cooper Rex
Rex you got does this genius have any
other
ones uh the last two suggestions were
Owen and rth
not feeling those not those ones Owen
Owen Owen's
nice Arturo I mean I do like that
name wow Arty for short mhm they also
pointed
out Ela says I need to think about it
don't hate it interesting we have a lot
like that though we have a lot of like
don't hate
it Rex
that's a that's aggressive name
Rex
Bru it's a powerful name
yeah um all right what the are we
doing thank you for the Dono here's
alfredo with a with a
fade urgent urgent
message
alfredo with a
low he's Gilling that he looks good yeah
[Music]
IM
n wow so updates Jeff says we'll do the
show live great guy great guy so on
Thursday then I'll be on Jeff's show
live and does that get me off the
hook I think so uh ultimately it's up
it's a lot two shows like that is is a
lot what what time a day does Jeff do
his thing I think we're going live
around 1 let me check my calendar okay
well that's usually when you go live so
uh Thursday at 12 or I mean at 12 yeah
yeah um people going to have the same
amount of content as they if you didn't
do it also Jeff says tell Dan to relax
I'm the most reliable thoughtful and
most humble person in this game I
believe
him Bachelor is my priority and it's
going to be a Smash Hit that's
convincing did he really say that or you
you're adding that I which part is
unbelievable to you the whole message to
me part no it says tell Dan to relax cuz
you were stressing about it being a
show he said I saw the clip from today
tell Dan to
relax okay it's not about you Jeff
specifically it's just you have to
understand there's a lot of uh there's a
lot of history here a lot of don't tell
him about the history don't tell him
about all he knows is that it's worked
out twice there's been two lasting loves
from this I mean that is technically
true it's not technically true it is
true definitely true technically it's
like absolutely true missing maybe a
little bit of context I see San every
day well Moses and Trisha are happily
married and they have kids are you
coming after Ian and Sam no Ian and Sam
they're a great couple okay so what's
technical about it all mhm it's just
there was a little bit more to The Saga
than that
really relates the end result is all
that matters it's not the destination
that matters as they say it's the no in
this case the journey is the issue it's
not the journey you're trying to say
it's the destination that matters not
the journey that's what I'm saying
[Music]
yeah Kanye can we get much higher can we
get less Jewish
ah is that Kanye can we get more
Jewish I like yes
sucks yeah we're going to need to see
more from him before I give the official
pass on that GNA need to see more I hope
he does what you said ab and gives a a
video or
something yeah well that was the rumor
right was a rumor where's that rumor
come
from his PR his press what's taking so
long shoot the video really working on
it he's really got to think hard he
delays his albums all the time you know
he's delaying his apology so all right I
think we're at of time what time is it
uh yeah we're we're pretty much out of
here also it is raining dude
it's coming down yeah I like it oh
this is from J post Jerusalem Post they
have an article saying Kanye West set to
apologize for anti-Semitism a 40-minute
video
report okay what's their Intel let's see
Kanye West is said to
apologize 40 minute long video which
will be released ahead of the launch of
his new album volur on February 7th cool
nice nice to you know an apology is
sincere when it's uh coordinated with an
album release
absolutely and the vultures are not a
reference to Jews
for the record all right that would not
that would be very
anti-semitic um according to Yahoo the
fact that the launch of the video
coincides with that of the album
suggests the video is more of a
publicity stunt or an image rebranding
rather than an actual expression of
remorse of his past action hey what is
this
editorial wow anti-semite of the year
yeah that was a well that was a well
well earned yeah that was earned that
you know deserve who was going to beat
him out
not even I think like he he I was going
to say he might beat Hitler in some of
his better years but I don't think so no
he hasn't killed anyone myge so that
he's pretty much several notches down
yeah and we're we're glad for that let's
keep it that way that is good let's keep
it that way keep that record down at
zero yeah all right well listen
everybody it's been fun it's been great
thank you everyone for being here thank
youone for donating and supporting I I
love you is there anything else to read
I don't want to leave anyone hanging
um to be honest there were yeah there's
a decent amount more let me try and just
hit like the big ones at least here yeah
let's let's go uh let's see that one's
50 I got that one earlier uh I think you
got this one the maximilan August Klein
right uh Dean
Klein I like Dean that's a sweet name
upper Dean upper Dean an upper decker
pretty
okay there's a fan named Dean he's the
one that made that really cool Teddy
fresh helmet oh we love Dean it's a
great
name are you reading or should I read I
was going off the other list but uh he
just dropped a bunch of unread ones if
you want to read those real quick in the
donation group just in the main oh in
the
main let's see Manny five gifted thank
you so much so is it the message above
that or no no that one was just a five
gifted Jordan says my dog passed away
this weekend everyone hug your fur
babies extra tight yeah there's no pain
like losing our babies I know it I will
sorry about that b will hug my fur
babies um s says please do a baby name
consultation with M Doodles and stuff
she's a genius and guest influencer baby
names correctly multiple times well
she's like a baby soothsayer oh sounds
kind
of was that the girl that you
look her up it was a post yeah that was
in our chat oh so she's some kind of
name psychic she's GNA say
Oliver that would be so
good if that's what she busted out uh
yeah that could be fun sir Tanuki dookie
Ethan seems to really be uh into
psychology of how people react to your
names my name is RA is it RAB RAB and
people seem to attack to my name it is
Jewish I've uh I've known a RAB
before RAB a Rab in elementary school
another one besides me not an
aab Jimmy Lee I knew aab not an aab got
it got it uh Lizzy says Hi I'm the
person who half jokingly requested a
recommendation for grad school just
wanted to update and say I submitted my
application wait did I I didn't ever
wrote you something did
I I kind of remember that
exchange on see you next Tuesday and no
I I think you said they don't you don't
want a recommendation from me you said
you would sign something if she sent it
to you but I don't think that it sounds
you can forge my signature you can if
anyone needs a letter of recommendation
you
can nothing else though only I'm not
permitting that on anything else a
letter recommendation only I could have
done that when you to schools to schools
I'll even be more specific yeah there
you go you know what let's not do this
no
don't do uh somebody just threw out $10
and said I was literally opening chat to
suggest Declan that's my son's name oh
sounds good with an a middle name Declan
we got a second second support for
Declan here so we've done them all
now uh pretty much uh a $20 just came
through and said Birch Klein I don't
know any other Birches and it's been a
good strong name for me Birch is a cute
nickname oh birie bir cute nickname bir
that's interesting I like you guys have
some good ideas today
Birch they say plus I'm your biggest fan
so you should commemorate me well that's
good enough raason right
there Felix bir is a very common last
name in we Sigma
Sigma yeah name him Sigma the final boss
of video game series Mega Man
X
H I heard you like that Gab you've
always been a fan of it all right so
tomorrow we so again just to emphasize
tomorrow there'll be no see you next
Tuesday it's moving to Thursday tomorrow
we'll be shooting some fun extras for
the show
yeah then on Thursday even though we
moved it to Thursday I'll be live with
Jeff right do a poll does that get me
off the
hook I can't do two in a row you guys
got to give me a break I got to live my
life a little bit two live shows back to
back I mean what am I uh well
maybe what am I what if Jeff's show is
such a disaster that you need to go live
to do damage control sure yeah that that
obviously yeah I'd probably wait though
till
Friday yeah okay right I mean it's the
same amount of content people are
getting I don't see this he doesn't have
a
button
right I'm going to be so I'm going to be
like so unfunny and uninteresting I'm
just be like yeah
no I guess sure sure okay all right
listen thank you guys thank you to
everybody for supporting the channel
thank you for watching love all y'all so
much shedy
Klein in order to comprehend you're
going to have to break
some
comprehend the frankly we have we have
respect for those eggshells we like him
[Music]
now in order to comprehend you're going
to have to break
some comprehend in order to comprehend
we see you guys on Wednesday a great
every knowledge you're going to need to
break those
[Music]
eggshells